THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON RULES WILL COME TO ORDER SO
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I WILL
BE MAKING SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY TO EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED TO
CONTINUE OUR ESSENTIAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THROUGH IT
AGAIN FOR THOSE TUNING IN FOR
THE VERY FIRST TIME. I'M GOING
TO COVER THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
THINGS FOR THE DAY. IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE HAVE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS.
OF THE PUBLIC OF COURSE TO OUR
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WITH WEBSITE. I'M
GOING TO REPEAT IT MULTIPLE
TIMES THROUGHOUT THE DAY. ARE
SO THAT YOU HAVE IT AND TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
TWO ONE FIVE SO I HOPE YOU HAVE
A PEN IN YOUR WRITING IT DOWN
I'LL REPEAT IT. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT TWO
ONE FIVE YOU NEED AN ACCESS
CODE AND THAT ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT TWO NINE
ONE. ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT TWO
NINE ONE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID FEEDBACK YOU MUST BE USED
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU SO
WE THANK YOU FOR. YOUR PATIENCE
AND FORMER I. TAKE IN THOSE
DIRECTIONS. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND INDEED ANY%
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
HEARING SERVICE OUR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. SO AGAIN PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR COURT REPORTER I WILL ASK
ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES A LIKE TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- AND I
SHOULD LET FOLKS KNOW THAT WE
HAVE MULTIPLE HEARINGS GOING ON
AT THE SAME TIME THERE IS A
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING AND A
BUDGET HEARINGS. AND MEMBERS OF
THIS RULES COMMITTEE SERVE ON
THOSE OTHER COMMITTEE SO YOU
MAY SEE PEOPLE COMING AND GOING
BUT OUR- WERE USED TO THAT BUT
I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
TAKING PLACE. SO MEMBERS AS A
REMINDER YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE FOR THE ROLL
CALL AND EVERY TIME THAT WE DO
TAKE A VOTE AND WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR US. GROWTH KAMLAGER
YOUR LONGER HERE LAYERED
CLEARED HERE GATE UPDATE YOUR
NEEDS HERE ATKINS HERE I CAN
HEAR THANK YOU AND- I KNOW THAT
SENATOR ROVE WILL BE HERE SHE
IS ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
SHE'S ALSO I THINK ON BUDGET.
SO SHE'S DOING THREE COMMITTEES
TODAY SO IF THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS I WANT TO TAKE UP ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND THAT WOULD BE ITEMS
TO D. F. THESE ARE MEMBERS OF
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION I WOULD SO MOVE THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED- ADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
GROVE KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES ALL
RIGHT EIGHT I ATKINS HI ATKINS
I. SO WE WILL- WE WILL GIVE OUR
COLLEAGUE A CHANCE TO CATCH HER
BREATH WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR THE MOMENT. AND COME BACK
TO IT. LET ME ASK IF I COULD
HAVE A MOTION ON BILL REFERRALS
REFERENCE OF BILLS TO COMMITTEE
THERMO THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED THIS IS YOUR BILL
REFERRALS ITEM NUMBER THREE.
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROW FIVE ROWS I
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI LAYERED
HI THERE I BATES HI EIGHT I
HAPPEN HI ADNAN FIVE FIVE TWO
ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO. AND CENTER
GROVE I'VE ALREADY EXPLAINED TO
THE PUBLIC THAT YOU'RE SERVING
ON THREE COMMITTEES TODAY AND
THE WE DID TAKE UP AND HAVE
OPENED THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO BOOT
PEERED THE THROUGH F.
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
DID YOU. ARE YOU PREPARED TO
VOTE ON THAT IF I OPEN THE ROLE
YES MA'AM. MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL ROVE HI PRO FIVE FIVE
ZERO THANK YOU THAT IS OUT
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES SO WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TURN NOW TO
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE I ITEM ONE A. AND
THAT'S THE APPOINTMENT OF MRS
RACHEL M. WAGNER AS DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES.
RECYCLING AND RECOVERY. I IT IS
GOOD TO SEE YOU DIRECTOR- IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF OZ. ANYONE THAT MIGHT
BE WITH YOU OR THAT YOU WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. AND THEN MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE AND AFTER THAT
INTRODUCTION I WILL GO RIGHT
INTO COMMENTS FOR OUR TWO
COLLEAGUES FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WELCOME. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
ACTIONS AND MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE IT IS SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE
TO BE WITH YOU TODAY. AND BACK
IN THE SENATE AT FEELS A LITTLE
LIKE COMING HOME AND I JUST
WISH I COULD BE THERE IN PERSON
WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY- BUT IT
IS WONDERFUL TO SEE ALL OF YOU
UP THERE ON THE DíAS OF THE
HEARING ROOM THAT I KNOW. TO
HELPED AND SAID THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'M I KNOW YOU ALL HAVE A
LOT GOING ON TODAY SO I'LL MAKE
MY OPENING STATEMENTS REALLY.
VERY BRIEF- I QUICKLY WANT TO
JUST TAKE KNOWLEDGE AND SAY
THANK YOU TO MY PARENTS AND
FIVE BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO.
ARE WATCHING FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY TODAY- AND EXTEND A
VERY SPECIAL THANK YOU TO MY
HUSBAND AND OUR AMAZING TWO
CHILDREN WHO ARE SITTING NEXT
TO ME TODAY. AND IT IS THEIR
UNWAVERING SUPPORT THAT HAS
ALLOWED ME TO DEDICATE SO MUCH
OF MY ENERGY TO SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND I AM
SO DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE TO MY
FAMILY SUPPORT. I'M SO WITH
THAT I JUST I WANT TO OPEN BY
AND MAKING A QUICK STATEMENT IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU.I'M AS
YOU ALL KNOW ONLY TOO WELL
CALIFORNIA IS AT A CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL CROSSROADS. THIS
YEAR ALONE WILDFIRES DROUGHT
AND EXTREME HEAT. ARE ALL
LOUDLY SINGLE SIGNALING THAT
OUR CLIMATE IS NOT ONLY
CHANGING BUT HAS CHANGED. AND
WE CAN NO LONGER DELAY OR
MITIGATION EFFORTS AND WE NEED
TO QUICKLY BECOME A MORE
RESILIENT CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS LONG LED THE NATION IN
PROGRESSIVE RECYCLING WASTE
LOTS AND WE'VE MADE INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS. AND A CONVERSATION
JUST THIS MORNING WITH A MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE. WE TALKED
ABOUT A LANDFILL THAT WAS DUE
TO REACH CAPACITY AND CLOSE IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE. BUT NOW IS
NOWHERE NEAR THAT FULL CAPACITY
AND THAT IS INCREDIBLE PROGRESS
HOWEVER THERE IS ALSO. MUCH
MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
IN THIS COUNTRY NEAR 4% OF THE
FOOD PRODUCED NOT EATEN. BUT
RATHER ENDS UP IN OUR
LANDFILLS. TURNING INTO METHANE
EIGHTY FOUR TIMES MORE POTENT.
THAN CARBON. ORGANIC WASTE
INCLUDING FOOD ACCOUNTS FOR
NEARLY HALF OF WHAT WE DISPOSE
OF HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND OUR
MOST RECENT NUMBERS SHOW THAT
CALIFORNIA THREW AWAY TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION TONS OF ORGANIC
WASTE. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. 12% OF OUR RESTRAINT
WAS PLASTICS THAT'S OVER FOUR
MILLION TIMES IN A SINGLE YEAR.
WE ARE DIVERTING AND RECYCLING
37% OF OUR RESTRAINT. WE SIMPLY
NEED TO DO BETTER AND MUCH MUCH
BETTER. I BELIEVE IS A STATE WE
ARE WELL POISED TO NOT ONLY DO
BETTER REDUCE OUR WASTE AND
LESSEN OUR IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT TO TURN OUR
WASTE INTO A RESOURCE AND USE
IT TO RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC
STRONGER FUTURE PROOFING OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR EXCITEMENT AND
LEAVING HEALTHIER STRONGER
STATE TO THE NEXT GENERATION.
OUR CHILDREN. HOW CYCLE HAS A
CRITICAL CRITICAL ROLE TO PLAY
BY LAYING THE FOUNDATION FOR A
TRUE CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND
EVENTUALLY AND ZERO WASTE
ECONOMY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY WORKING WITH YOU
THE LEGISLATURE. TO ATTRACT NEW
INNOVATIVE COMPANIES NEW JOBS
AND NEW INDUSTRIES THAT SHARE
OUR VISION OF AND NEVER ENDING
LIFE CYCLE FOR OUR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS. I BELIEVE MY LIFE AND
CAREER EXPERIENCE HAS PREPARED
ME AND LED ME TO THIS MOMENT TO
HELP CALIFORNIA DO JUST THAT I
GREW UP UNDERSTANDING THE TRUE
VALUE OF OUR RESOURCES. MY
FAMILY FATHER'S FAMILY ARRIVED
IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH THE
CLOTHES ON THEIR BACK AND MY
MOTHER'S FAMILY GREW UP ON A
MIDWESTERN FARM. ALL LIVED AND
WORKED THROUGH THE GREAT
DEPRESSION AND THE WORLD WARS
AND TAUGHT US. TO NEVER WASTE
ANYTHING WE GREW UP GROWING OUR
OWN FOOD COMPOSTING RECYCLING
ALL FROM AN EARLY AGE AND BEING
ONE OF SIX CHILDREN CAN BE
DOWNS WERE OUR VERSION OF NEW
CLOTHES. AND I STILL LOOK
FORWARD TO MY OLDER SISTER
SANDY DISCOUNTS WHEN NAY COME
ABOUT. AND WHAT IT IS NEARLY MY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN PUBLIC
SERVICE WITH BEST LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR THAT I BELIEVE
HIS POSITION ME TO TAKE ON THIS
CHALLENGE AND WORK WITH YOU. TO
BUILD A TRUE CIRCULAR ECONOMY
THAT WILL LEAD OUR STATE. OUR
NATION AND OUR PLANET. WITH
THAT I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME TODAY
AND I AM WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MEDEVACED
HERE GIVEN THAT I KNOW YOU WERE
GONNA HAVE TO STEP WAIT A
MINUTE DO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
START ON THIS ONE AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO SENATOR LAYERED IF
THAT'S- OKAY. ABSOLUTELY
ESPECIALLY WITH THE FOR A YOUNG
LADY WHO I KNOW WELL FOR
ENOUGH. A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN
SHE WAS THE- CONSULTANT ON THAT
YOU GET COMMITTEE RIDE
COMMISSION WAGNER SO. GREAT TO
SEE YOU- I OF. I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
SNOWING UP OF RECYCLING PROGRAM
REALLY HIT. YOU KNOW THE WALLS-
COUPLE YEARS AGO- WITH THE- YOU
KNOW CHINESE NOT ACCEPTING OUR-
ARE. RECYCLED MATERIAL ETCETERA
ETCETERA AND THEN A- COUPLE
BILLS PASSED ACTUALLY WAS SB
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT AND A B. FIFTY
FOUR WHICH I DID SUPPORT.
ALTHOUGH FOR PILOT PROGRAMS AND
THERE'S A REPORT YOU I BELIEVE
IN JANUARY ARE COMING UP. BUT
CAN YOU GIVE US ANY OF THE
LITTLE PEEKABOO NOW ON HOW
THOSE HAVE WORKED IN TERMS OF
INCENTIVIZING OUR- RECYCLING.
EFFORTS AGAIN- AS WE RECEIVED
SO MANY COMPLAINTS FROM
CONSTITUENTS AND YOU KNOW. THAT
THERE WASN'T ANY PLACE AND THEY
WERE STILL SAVING ALL OF THEIR-
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL SO HOW'S
THAT WORKING AND NOW IT DOESN'T.
GIVE A **** ANY RAY OF HOPE.
WELL I'LL- YOU PRINT SENATOR SO
I'M FIRST INFORM I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE PILOT
PROJECTS AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR US TO-
AND EXECUTES MEDICINAL PILOT
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE AND I
THINK THIS IS A REAL.
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA AND
CAL RECYCLED TO LOOK AT AND-
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER INNOVATIVE
WAYS WHERE WE CAN BREAK THE
LOGJAM ON AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AROUND. BOTTLING
HAND AND BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING IN CALIFORNIA I WILL
SAY THAT. I WOULD PROJECTS THAT
HAD AND THEN OPERATIONS OUR OUR
AND WE'RE A LITTLE SLOW AND THE
PANDEMIC SLOWED EVERYTHING DOWN
AND SAY OH I THINK WE NOW HAVE
ALL SIGNS. THAT ARE FULLY
FUNDED AND WORKING ON THEIR
LUNCHES BUT THEY ALL ARE
TESTING DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES-
AND DIFFERENT SYSTEMS THAT WE
ARE VERY EXCITED TO SEE I HAD
AND WHAT THEY COME UP WITH BUT
IT MAY BE A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
UNTIL WE SEE THE OUTCOMES THE
PANDEMIC REALLY AND AS YOU KNOW
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE SAVING
THEIR BOTTLES AND CANS. AND IT
REALLY AND INHIBITED STARTING
ANYTHING NEW AT BUT WE ARE
WORKING WITH THOSE FIVE
JURISDICTIONS. TO YOU- LAUNCH
THEIR PILOT PROJECTS AND THEN
WORKING WITH OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. I'M IN SOME OF
OUR UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
PARTS OF THE STATE LIKE UP IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY I'M SOME AREAS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY Q. LOOKED TO
THOSE JURISDICTIONS AND SIGNED
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY AND HAVE
COME TO US AND SAID IF YOU GET
ADDITIONAL AUTHORIZATION WE
WOULD LOVE TO PARTICIPATE SO WE
ARE IN THE EARLY CONVERSATIONS.
WITH SOME OTHER JURISDICTIONS
ABOUT HI EXCITING NEW IDEAS AND
TO IN INCREASE OUR. AND OUR
BOTTLE AND CAN RECYCLING. GOOD
NEWS THERE WILL BE YOU ARE
THINK AND- AWAITING ON FROM THE
DAY YOU MAY MORE TO IS WHAT I'M
HEARING ARE TO HAVE A REAL
ACCURATE COUNT IS WHETHER WE-
YOU KNOW WE FELL TO A LITTLE
BELOW 70% AND WE STARTED OUT-
IN THE EIGHTY PERCENT. THAT WAS
REALLY AN EXCITING THING I
REMEMBER WHEN IT WAS. REQUIRED
WAS AB WITH OF AB EIGHTY NINE
I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER BUT AND
I WE HAD JUST STARTED OUR CITY
AND- THERE WAS GRUMBLING ABOUT
IT. BUT INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
THE KIDS AT SCHOOL OUR CHILDREN
WERE WERE BEING EDUCATED ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BRING THAT
HOME IT GAROFALO VERY INVOLVED
TOO SO. GOOD PROGRAM ARE ONE
OTHER QUICK QUESTION. THE COST
OF DOING BUSINESS HAS REALLY
AREN'T I THINK. I DAHLE THE
MOLE THE MARKET OR THE IN THE
INTEREST OF BUSINESSES WANTING
TO INCREASE RECYCLING-
MARKETING CALIFORNIA ARE YOU
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE MIGHT.
RE OFFEND TO VICE- OUR
BUSINESSES WASN'T HE I'M TRYING
TO MEMBER THAN THE NAME OF THE
BUSINESS THAT WAS REALLY AT THE
HEADWATERS AND THEY QUIT DOING
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF THE CAR OFF
TÁI IT WAS. ACTUALLY ON MORE
EXPENSIVE TO DO TO DO WITH. THE
RECYCLING ALL PROGRAMS FAN ARE
WHAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
RECEIVING IN TERMS OF
REMUNERATION SO IF YOU CAN DIE
SHARE SOME THOUGHT SHE MIGHT.
BE LOOKING OUT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT
OF THE WHOLE. ISSUE WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SENATOR I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU. I
THINK IS EXACTLY THE
CONVERSATION THAT I WANT TO
HAVE WITH ALL OF YOU AND
LEGISLATURE. I'M AROUND AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED
IN TERMS OF FUNDING AND ON THE
ON GOING CONVERSATION THIS YEAR
AROUND HOW DO WE BUILD THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSED SPENDING SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. AND MEANT
SPECIFICALLY TO FILL THE GAPS
AND REALLY MAKE CALIFORNIA A
COMPETITIVE PLACE FOR RECYCLING
AND REMANUFACTURING. AND ONE OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT IS AND AS I
ASKED YOU GOT VERY EXCITED
ABOUT IS A VERY SMALL PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAD. THAT WOULD HELP
WITH FUNDING FOR DEVELOPMENT
AND BUSINESS PLANS FOR
INNOVATIVE BUSINESSES IN
RECYCLING. AND REMANUFACTURING
AND AS YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT AND- IN THE PAST.
OFTENTIMES THE BIGGEST HURDLE
INTO STARTING A BUSINESS IS
GETTING THAT INITIAL SUPPORT
AND SO. WE HAVE I'M SPENT THE
LAST SIX MONTHS SINCE I CAME ON
BOARD REALLY TALKING ABOUT
WHERE THE GAPS IN THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. AND THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN STEP IN AND CREATE
INCENTIVES. AND SUPPORT FOR OUR
BUSINESSES THE KINDS OF
BUSINESSES WE'D LIKE TO SEE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS AND- WITH THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE. AND I THINK IT'S A
VERY VERY EXCITING AREA WHERE
THERE IS MARKED IMPROVEMENT. TO
BE MADE BUT MARKED IMPROVEMENT
THAT WE CAN MAKE. THAT'S GREAT
NEWS AND CERTAIN YOU'LL BE.
LEGISLATORS AND SOME OF THOSE
PLANS WITHOUT I THINK THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT'S GOING
FORWARD THAT WE'VE SEEN AND ON
THE ON ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE. ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES SOME OF THEM CONTENTIOUS
BUT OTHER STUFF. HAVE FROM THE
REAL INNOVATIVE THINKING ON ON
HOW TO MAKE IT A PARTNERSHIP
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE-
I ASKED WE HAD OUR WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE RECENT MEETING THAT.
I'M TRYING TO THINK THAT WAS
JUST A COUPLE MONTHS AGO PRETTY
CLOSE. EVERYTHING IS BLURRED
WITH PROVISION WE HAD SOME
GREAT CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT
SO IT'S A- SUPER TO SEE THAT ON
THE TOP OF YOUR LIST OF THE-
GOALS TO ACHIEVE IN THIS FIRST
YEAR SO. OUR CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR NOMINATION AND- YOU WILL
HAVE MY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SO MUCH
APPRECIATED AND IF I DON'T SEE
YOU HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON WITH
THE- THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
CENTER LAYERED YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I'M GONNA PICK
UP WHERE. SENATOR BATES LEFT
OFF AND THANK YOU FOR I WILL
ASK MYSELF TO SAY IT WAS MY
LANDFILLS YOU WERE REFERRING
TO. US OUT OF OUR DISCUSSION
BUT IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT POINT
BECAUSE WHEN I WENT ON THE CITY
COUNCIL ALMOST EIGHT EIGHTY
FORTY YEARS AGO IT SEEMS LIKE
EIGHTY ALMOST FORTY YEARS AGO
THE CITY MANAGER SAYS. IF YOU
STAY HERE LONG ENOUGH WE HAVE
TWENTY YEARS LIFE ON OUR
LANDFILL YOU WILL BE HERE FOR
THE CLOSURE ACTIVITIES IN THE
CITING THE NEXT LANDFILLS AND
NOW FORTY YEARS LATER THE
LANDFILL THAT HAD TWENTY YEARS
LIFE ON IT HAS THIRTY THREE
YEARS LIFE ON IT AND THE
REASON. THAT IT'S GONE THAT WAY
AND HAS EXPANDED LARGEST
PROGRAM YOU ARE ADMINISTERING
BUT THEN IT RAISES QUESTIONS
AND ONE OF THEM WE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY. IS THE BILL THAT THAT
SENATOR BATES REFERRED TO THAT
WAS PASSED IN IT IN THE LATE.
DROWNED OUT. TRYING DOWNTURN
THIS OFF. IT HAPPENED DOT ORG
OUR CAUCUS RETREAT AND IT WAS
JERRY BROWN AND EVERYBODY WAS
SITTING AROUND ME IN A PLACE
THAT'S OKAY HE CALLED THE REST
OF US AFTER YOU DIDN'T HEAR.
EXACTLY. AND WE ALL KNOW WHAT
ABOUT OF EACH. AND SO THE THING
ABOUT IT IS THE TIP FEE THAT
WAS IN THAT INITIAL BILL FUNDED
DIVERSION RATE THE- TO CHANGE
SO DRAMATICALLY AND SUCCESS ARE
COMES WITH LOSING YOUR FUNDING
SOURCE THE MORE YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL THE LAST FUNDING YOU
CASH BECAUSE IT CAME FROM THE
TIP FEE TO FUND SO
NOW THAT YOU'RE INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL YOU DON'T HAVE- OF.
THAT TO DO OUR PART HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO DEAL WITH OUT OVER
TIME. AND IF YOU WANT TO
DIPLOMATICALLY SAY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD HELP US I'M.
HOW YOU GOING TO DEAL WITH THEM.
YEAH YOU READ MY MIND SENATOR
LARRY AS A GOOD FORMER
LEGISLATIVE STAFFER I KNOW TO
NEVER STEP INTO THE WORLD OF
APPROPRIATIONS SPREAD OUT I
HAVE WITH OUT FULL BACK UP OF
MY- OF THE LEGISLATURE AND BUT
I THINK YOU KNOW AS WE
DISCUSSED THIS MORNING THIS IS
A HUGE CHALLENGE THAT. AND YOU
KNOW I WOULD LOVE TO WORK OUR
CYCLE AND ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES
ASSIGNED TO BE PUT OUT OF
BUSINESS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY WASTE BUT THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THERE'S INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
AS PROGRAMS THAT HELP. BUILD
AND MAINTAIN COMPOSTING
FACILITIES RECYCLING FACILITIES
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS EFFORTS
THOSE ARE I'M PRIMARILY FUNDED
AND RUN THE AND THAT THE TIPSY
SIGNED BINDING AND SO I THINK
THAT IT IS SOMETHING IN THERE
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW THAT
FUND IS VERY HEALTHY THIS WAS A
VERY HIGH DISPOSAL YEAR AS- WE
HONOR- AND KEVIN WOULD BRING.
AND BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT
AND HOPEFULLY AT AND I THINK
AND AUSPICIOUSLY WILL DECREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE COMING
YEARS AND WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FIND THAT ANY
EFFORTS THAT ARE HELPING OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND HELPING OUR
COMMUNITIES I'M AND- WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME INTENSELY
DECREASING AT. THE EIGHT NOW
THEY WERE DISPOSING UP. AND
THEN I I'VE APPRECIATE AND IT'S
THAT WILL WORK ON THAT. ANOTHER
THING WE TALKED ABOUT AND I WAS
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR BECAUSE I
WAS ON THE WAY SUPPORT FOR A
YEAR AND WHEN I WAS ON THE
WHITE BOARD WITH OUR PLASTIC
RECYCLING. WE WERE REALLY GOOD
AT TAKING THE PLASTIC INTO THE
RECYCLING AND WE HAD
MANUFACTURERS THAT WANTED TO
USE THE PALLETS AND REUSE IT.
BUT WE DID NOT HAVE THE PEOPLE
IN BETWEEN TO MANUFACTURE THE
RECYCLING TO THE BALANCE. AND
THEN IN THE CIRCULAR PART OF IT
WE WERE MISSING THE MIDDLE
PART. ARM IS THAT STILL A
PROBLEM AND IF THAT'S STILL A
PROBLEM HOW DO YOU SUGGEST WE
ADDRESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION SENATOR LARRY
THAT IS DISTINCTLY THE PROBLEM
THAT AND I CAME ON BOARD. AND
TO ADDRESS UNFORTUNATELY EVERY
TEN YEARS WE HAVE NOT FOUND THE
MAGIC BULLET THAT WILL. WILL
ADDRESS THAT SITUATION I'M SO
EITHER IN MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE. I AND AS A
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT I COULD
SEE THAT THERE WERE GAPS THAT
EXISTED IN OUR SYSTEM BUT I
COULDN'T QUITE FIGURE OUT WHERE
THEY WERE AND STILL COMING ON
BOARD AS DIRECTOR SIX MONTHS
AGO MY TOP ONE OF MY TOP GOALS.
AND AS MANY ONE OF MY DOUBLES
WAS IDENTIFIED THE SPECIFIC
APPS. AND AS AND YOU ALL KNOW
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THERE
WERE SPECIFIC APPROPRIATIONS
FOR SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THOSE
WERE VERY MUCH MEANT. TO START
TO ADDRESS TO LAY THE
FOUNDATION TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE GAPS. IN RECYCLING AND
CREATING THIS THE TRUE
CIRCULARITY AND- AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS AND HE BURKE HOLDING.
I'M IN CALIFORNIA WE CREATE A
LOT OF CYBER. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT IF WE COULD GET RECYCLED
AND WE ALSO HAVE AND SOME
REMANUFACTURING HERE AS
RECYCLED FIBER THAT HAPPENS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHAT
WE'RE NOT DOING IS ACTUALLY
RECYCLING FIBER AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LOST OUT ON
SEVERAL COMPANIES. AND THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THE FEEDSTOCK WAS HERE.
AND THEN ENDED UP GOING TO
OTHER STATES AND THAT JUST MADE
MORE BUSINESS SENSE FOR THEM
SO. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE AND
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
BUILD PROGRAMS THAT DRAW THOSE
COMPANIES THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE RECYCLING
THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO RECYCLE. AND PROVIDING THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS UNITIES I'M
THE JOBS IN COMMUNITIES THE WAY
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM BUILT
AND BUILDING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND REALLY. LAID THE GROUNDWORK
AND DEFINITION OF WHAT A TRUE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY IS WHICH IS
NOT JUST RECYCLING. RECYCLING
IN A WAY THAT THEN SETS THE
COMMUTER AND THE- AND THEN. WE
TALK A LITTLE BIT TODAY WHAT'S
STATUS OF TIRE RECYCLING AT
THIS. I DIDN'T GET THAT NUMBER
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR ASKING.
I HAVE IT RIGHT HERE HE ASKED
ME FOR HOW MUCH WE RECYCLE AND
I DIDN'T HAVE T OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD WHICH I WAS A LITTLE
EMBARRASSED ABOUT BECAUSE I
LITERALLY HAD READ OUR AND
DRAFT HIGHER PLANNED. TWO DAYS
AGO. I'M THAT I'M TOLD. IS AND-
GENERATING FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN. JUST OVER FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND TONS.
OF TIRES- WE ARE DIVERTING
ABOUT EIGHTY TWO PERCENT. I'M
FROM LANDFILLS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT WAS DOWN FROM 92%
WHICH IS UNFORTUNATE. AND YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF RECYCLING. AND
WE'RE RECYCLING ABOUT THIRTY
SEVEN PERCENT. AND I WILL STATE
THAT THE SILVER LINING. WELL
FIRST I'D LIKE TO SAY I'D LIKE
TO BE DOING A LOT BETTER. AND
TIRES HOWEVER AS YOU KNOW ARE
VERY CHALLENGING MATERIAL. I'M
AND BY BETTER I WANT TO DO IT
IN A WAY THAT IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY HELPFUL AND- IS
NOT PERPETUATING AT PRACTICES
THAT AREN'T GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT I WILL SEE THE
SILVER LINING IS THAT THIS
PROGRAM HAS SPENT INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL. AND IN DIVERTING
FROM LANDFILLS. AND CUTTING WAY
BACK AND- THEY ILLEGAL DISPOSAL
OF TIRES. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
IN THE CREATION OF THIS
PROGRAM. WAS CUTTING WAY BACK
ON THAT AND NUMBER OF. FIRES
I'M FROM STOCKPILED TYRES. AND
WE HAVE NOT YET. AND WHEN SHE
SAYS BUT WE HAVE NOT SEEN A
FIRE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
TRACY FIRE. I'M SINCE THE INS
AND COMMENCEMENT OF THIS
PROGRAM. AND SO I'LL TAKE THAT
AS A HUGE SUCCESS BUT UCH MORE
WORK TO BE DONE. NUMBER AND-
WHAT WENT HERE WE TALK ABOUT
TIRES AND WE'RE RECYCLING AND
ONE SILO AND- WE HAVE
ELECTRONICS THAT WE RECYCLE. IN
A SILO. OR HAVE EXTENDED
PRODUCER OF PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY SILO. HOW DO WE
MOVE TO EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S ACROSS
THE BOARD IT JUST NOT IN SILOS.
OR OR LET'S JUST SAY BROADER.
THAT RATHER THAN A CAR THE HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH WHOLE ISSUE
EXTEND PRODUCER. THANKS SUCH
INCREDIBLY. MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION FOR ME AND I THINK
THAT IS WHY WE REALLY WANT TO
START THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW DO WE BUILD
A CIRCULARECONOMY A TRUE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE IT TO A PLACE
WHERE MANUFACTURERS ARE
DESIGNING. ALL OF THEIR
PRODUCTS OR THEIR NEXT LIFE AND
THAT WE ARE NOT DOING AS I LIKE
TO REFER AT THE LACK OF MORAL
AND TRYING TO RECYCLE THINGS
THAT WERE DESIGNED FOR
DISPOSAL. I'M WE AS YOU KNOW
HAS FOUR OR FIVE DEPENDING ON
HOW YOU JUST DEFINE IT PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP U. P. R. PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE MAKING
INCREDIBLE PROGRESS WHAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING. AS A STATE IS
WORKING WITH THOSE
MANUFACTURERS IN STATE AND OUT
OF STATE AND REALLY DEMANDING
THAT THEIR PRODUCTS ARE
DESIGNED. FOR THEIR NEXT LIFE
AND THE LIFE AFTER THAT. AN ARM
GOING TO TAKE THAT AS AN OPEN
INVITATION TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THAT SO THAT'S GREAT. IN THE
WEEKS. AND THEN THE LAST
QUESTION. IS ON ORGANICS WHICH
IS BEEN CENTRAL TO SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU'VE BEEN DOING
THERE'S A BILL THAT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED. I KNOW I'M DOING A
BILL TO WORK WITH THE CITIES TO
NOT RELAXED REQUIREMENTS BUT
THEY HAD A ROUGH YEAR COULD NOT
BE PENALIZED FOR THIS YEAR. AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PUT A
PHENOMENAL AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
THIS BUDGET THAT IS HEADED THE
GOVERNOR'S WHY. ARE IF YOU HAVE
THAT MONEY AND YOU DON'T RELAX
REQUIREMENTS WHERE DOES THAT
PUT US IN A SORT OF GETTING TO
THE DEADLINE AND MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS. WELL I THINK
WE'VE LAID SOME REALLY GOOD
GROUNDWORK IN THE LAST YEAR AND
AS WELL YOUR LAST WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO REALLY HAVE
THE TOOLS. MOVING FORWARD SO
I'M CYCLE ADOPTED OR I
REGULATIONS AND FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND OVER THE LAST
YEAR WE HAD AND- BUILDING TOOLS
LIKE MODEL ORDINANCES
EDUCATIONAL TOOLS PROCUREMENT
TOOLS. TO REALLY HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CECILY TAPE
THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REGULATIONS. I WE ARE ALSO
CONDUCTED HUNDREDS AS AN
INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS AS WELL AS
AND AS WEBINARS AND- AT LARGER
MEETINGS BETWEEN JURISDICTIONS
TO REALLY FACILITATE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM ON WHAT
THEY NEED TO CUT OR COMPLIANCE
AND I THINK THAT MANY THAT THE-
LEGISLATURE SPENT PORRIDGE.
THAT AND IS A POTENTIAL
INFUSION IN HELPING THEM BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND LAYING
THE GROUNDWORK FOR THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND FOR THE
APPROPRIATE MANAGEMENT AND
RECYCLING AND NOT WASTE THERE
IT'S A VERY EXCITING TIME I
THINK IT REALLY WELL ONCE AND
COMPLIANCE AND IMPLEMENTATION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SERRA. AND
WE REALLY SEE OUR ROLE AS
HELPING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
COME INTO COMPLIANCE AS YOU
KNOW THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS A
STATE WIDE REQUIREMENT OF 75%
TO BRITISCHEN OF ORGANIC WASTE.
AND BITE AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND UNFORTUNATELY AND WHILE WE
ARE DISPOSING OF MORE THAN OUR
BASELINE OF TWENTY FOURTEEN SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
BUT I THINK THE INFUSION OF
DOLLARS AND THE TOOLS THAT CAL
RECYCLE HAS BUILT AND- IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO VERY
QUICKLY. AS MAKE INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS RIGHT THANK YOU I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT TO AN
END THANK YOU MADAM. CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME. OF THE TIME TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS ARE REALLY. I
AS WE- SENATE GROWTH. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM MISS WAGNER I
APOLOGIZE PROFUSELY FOR
YESTERDAY MY MEETING JUST
BEFORE YOURS WENT- EXTRA LONG
AND ALTHOUGH I DID TRY TO GET
OUT OF IT I WAS NOT ABLE TO SO
I APOLOGIZE- FOR THAT. IT'S
DEFINITELY A PLEASURE TO HAVE
YOU BEFORE ME I JUST APPRECIATE
ALL THE TIME THAT YOU WERE VERY
HELPFUL AND ALWAYS RESPONSIVE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE-
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH AND
EXCITED THAT YOU'RE TAKING ON
THIS ROLE. I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT AT CURBSIDE
RICART CYCLING AND MERSE AND I
APOLOGIZE AGAIN FOR NOT BEING
ABLE TO SKETCH YESTERDAY. BUT I
KNOW THAT THE REGULATORY
PROCESS OF THE MANDATES THAT
FELL ON PRIVATE BUSINESS
INDUSTRY AND RECYCLERS. CREATED
A BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
A ROBUST RECYCLING PROGRAM
THAT- AS- ADDRESSES CURBSIDE
PICKUP AND- TAKING THE NUMBERS
TO SEPARATE AND RECYCLE. AND SO
I KNOW THERE'S A COUPLE OF
BILLS GOING THROUGH THE
BUILDING- AND I KNOW EVERYBODY
HAS THEIR OWN REPRESENTATION OF
THEIR OWN DISTRICT AND I
RESPECT THAT. BUT I DO HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT THAT SO WAS
CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT CURBSIDE PICKUP AND
IMMERSE. STOP ME IF I'M GOING
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION SENATOR
AT MAKE SURE I'M I'M I'M
UNDERSTANDING CORRECTLY IN
TERMS OF. WHERE I'M AT
DEPARTMENT AND MY PERSONAL AND
AS THE DIRECTOR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CURBSIDE PICKUP AND
MERCS I THINK. WE HAVE AS YOU
STATED INVESTED A LOT OF MONEY
IN AND INFRASTRUCTURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT HAS
DISABILITY DISORIENTATED EXCUSE
ME PICK UP AND ITS COLLECTION I
HAVE A LOT OF POTENTIALLY
RECYCLABLE MATERIALS. AND I
THINK WE SHOULD CONTINUE HERE
WITHOUT INVESTMENT THAT IS
SOMETHING BACK CALIFORNIANS
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA KNOWS
WHAT THE BLUE BANUS KNOWS HOW
TO USE THE BLUE BAND. I'M THAT
BEING SAID I THINK THERE ARE A
LOT OF IMPROVEMENTS THAT NEED
TO BE MADE TO OUR SYSTEM AND
BECAUSE A LOT OF WHAT IS
LANDING IN THE LUMEN IS NOT
ULTIMATELY ENDING UP BEING
RECYCLED. STILL I THINK THERE
IS AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
HERE WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ARE HAULERS AND RECYCLERS AND
ARMORS. TO WORK TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM BUT IT ISN'T
IT IS AN INCREDIBLE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE STARTED
IN. THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
WAS GROUNDBREAKING WHEN
CALIFORNIA STARTED. BUILDING
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK AND
AS OUR MATERIALS HAVE BECOME
MORE COMPLICATED AND
CONTAMINATION IT'S BECOME. A
REAL ISSUE AND WE SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER TO FIX IT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT OPPORTUNITY- I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW THAT
YOU WILL. ALWAYS BE OPEN TO ALL
SIDES SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
I'D LIKE YOU TO LOOK OUT AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD IN DEALING WITH
THIS- AND I CAN SEND YOU A LIST
AS WELL AS- IS AND CONVENIENCE
AND THE REASON WHY I SAY THAT
IS BECAUSE- WE LEARNED A LOT IN
THE PANDEMIC YOU KNOW WE
LEARNED ACT. AND PEOPLE WHOSE
JOBS WERE NOT DEEMED ESSENTIAL
HAD PROBLEMS PROVIDING FOOD FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR. FOUR
AMOUNT OF FOOD SO THAT PEOPLE
COULD BE WE GET ELIMINATE FOOD
INSECURITY PER SE. AND THEN WE
LEARNED WITH THE FOOD BANKS
THAT EVEN IN BAKERSFIELD IF YOU
HAD TO FOOD BANKS IN THE CITY
OF BAKERSFIELD. A SINGLE MOM
WITH THE STROLLER AND- YOU KNOW
TAKING TWO KIDS OR AN ELDERLY
WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN OR AT
INDIVIDUAL THAT. WAS NOT AT
VERY AMBULATORY HOW TO MAKE IT
EVEN IN A MILE OR TWO MILES
FROM THEIR HOME IN MUCH LESS
LOAD UP A FIFTY POUND BOX OF
FOOD AND BRING IT BACK. SO I
HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS
REGARDING- BILLS GOING THROUGH
THE BUILDING ABOUT GOING BACK
TO THE MANUFACTURER. AND WHAT
ABOUT THE SINGLE MOM THAT WOULD
NORMALLY THROW THEIR BOTTLES
OUT ON THE CURB- OR IN THE BLUE
VAN. BE PICKED UP BY A CURBSIDE
RECYCLING THAT COMES DOWN
EITHER TWICE OR ONCE A WEEK IN
HER NEIGHBORHOOD- THE ELDERLY
PERSONS NEIGHBORHOOD OR-
ANYBODY. I MEAN I MEAN I FEEL
LIKE I COULD PROBABLY TAKE IT
BACK TO THE MANUFACTURER BUT I
WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE HUGE
INCONVENIENCE TO LOOK AT. YOU
KNOW OUR SODA BOTTLES BEER CANS
WHATEVER THEY ARE AND TAKEN
BACK TO THE MANUFACTURER. AM I
JUST ASSUME LEAVING OUT ON THE
CURB AND HAVE SOMEBODY PICK
THEM UP I'M ALL ABOUT
CONVENIENCE. SO MOVING FORWARD
I'D LIKE YOU TO YOU KNOW
CONSIDER THOSE THINGS CONSIDER
THE FACT THAT. THE SINGLE MOM
MAY NOT HAVE TRANSPORTATION TO
TAKE IT ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
ROOM THE MANUFACTURER. AND THE-
ELDERLY PERSON THAT'S NON
AMBULATORY MAY NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO AND MAY I HAVE A
CAR- IN THE THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED IN THE PANDEMIC WERE.
YOU KNOW THE FOOD BANKS FOR
FABULOUS AND THEY SERVED A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF PEOPLE IF YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DRIVE
THROGH. BUT THE LAST MILE WAS
ALSO NEEDED TO DELIVER THAT-
FOOD INTO. THE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE PEOPLE. YOU KNOW MAYBE
COULDN'T MAKE IT TO THE FOOD
BANKS. AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING
I'D LIKE YOU TO LOOK AT MOVING
FORWARD SPECIFICALLY. I DON'T
SEE JUST FOR THE CONVENIENCE
ISSUE BUT IT'S CONVENIENCE IN
MANY WAYS- I NOTICED THAT WHEN-
THEY STUTTERED WITH THE TRASH
CANS SPECIFICALLY INTO A PLACE
AND OIL DEL. WE HAD IS LIKE A
TRAILER PARK IN. AND THEY HAVE
ALL THE LITTLE DIFFERENT TRASH
BINS BUT PEOPLE WOULD JUST
THROW THEIR GARBAGE ALL OVER IN
IN THEIR RESPIRE HILLS OF STUFF
THAT HAD TO BE PICKED UP. AS A
MATTER OF FACT WE REALIZE WHAT
WAS GOING ON HE WORKED WITH THE
LOCAL AND- GOVERNMENT THERE HE
PROVIDED US- YOU KNOW- BACKHOES
AND LOADERS TO PICK UP THIS.
GARBAGE THAT HAD BEEN COLLECTED
FOR MANY MANY AND YOU KNOW
MONTHS. AND BECAUSE I THINK
PEOPLE. AND I ASKED HIM. END
THIS IS WHAT GAVE ME A REALITY
CHECK IGHT SO I ASKED HIM WHEN
I WNT TO GO HELP AND WE
BROUGHT IN SINCE DEFINITELY.
YOU KNOW PREPARED MEALS AND-
YOU KNOW TRY TO TAKE HER THIS
VERY POOR AREA OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND I SAID YOU KNOW
WHY WOULD YOU LET STUFF PILE UP
LIKE THAT IN THE GUIDE
COMPLETELY ASLEEP RIGHT NOW
RYAN SAID. WOULD YOU WANT ME TO
DO WITH IT. IT DOESN'T IN THE
BLUE CANDLES FOR THE GREEN CAN.
AND I DON'T HAVE A CAR TO TAKE
IT TO THEM. AND THAT MADE
PERFECT SENSE TO ME. SO AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD WITH ALL THESE
THINGS I THINK THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- THAT HAS BEEN. PUT
FORWARD AND I'M NOT DEFENDING
ANY PARTICULAR INDUSTRY. I MEAN
THERE'S JUST A BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF- OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT IS A BIT PUT AT THE CREASE
A CONVENIENCE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHETHER YOU. NEED
THAT CONVENIENCE OR JUST
DESIRE. THAT CONVENIENCE. AND I
THINK MOVING FORWARD IT WOULD.
BE HUGE IF YOU WOULD AT LEAST
CONSIDER THAT. RAMIFICATION IF
CERTAIN CHANGES ARE MADE TO
THIS PROGRAM. AND THOSE
CONVENIENCES WOULD DISAPPEAR
FOR. YOU KNOW PEOPLE I GUESS
THAT ENJOY THE CONVENIENCE. AND
AND IT WOULD ALSO DISAPPEAR FOR
PEOPLE WHO DESPERATELY NEED
THAT CONVENIENCE- IN ORDER NOT
TO HAVE THAT PILOT IN THEIR
YARD. AS SO I'D LIKE YOUR
COMMITMENT IF YOU WOULD AT
LEAST LOOK AT THAT. SENATOR AND
AS ALWAYS HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND WORK
WITH YOU AS WE MAKE. ANY NUMBER
OF REFORM SAID THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMENT AND DEFINITELY WILL
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT AND
RECYCLING REFORM OVERALL. AND I
THINK YOU MAKE A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT PEOPLE ONLY RECYCLE AND
SO FAR AS THEY ARE. ABLE AND
WILLING AND IS BEING ANSWER-
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU I DO
APPRECIATE THAT. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF OTHER QUESTIONS IF
THAT'S OKAY AND MAYBE NOT AND
ALL OF THE ONES THAT I HAVE
HERE. AND SO HOW AT THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY MY
DISTRICT HAS EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT FINDING ENOUGH RECYCLED
PLASTIC- FOR THE- THERMOFORMED
CONTAINERS AND THAT ARE NEEDED.
I WHAT'S THE STATE DOING TO
ENCOURAGE RECYCLERS OF PLASTICS
TO MEET THE- UPCOMING MINIMUM
CONTENT DEADLINES. AND THIS IS
A NEAT A STICKY WICKET SQL
SENATOR DRIVE BECAUSE AND
THAT'S THURMOND FORMS ARE USING
THE SAME PLASTICS THAT INSTEAD
OF PLASTIC WATER BOTTLES AND
BEVERAGE CONTAINER BOTTLES ARE
USING AND NOW THERE IS A DEMAND
FOR ACTUALLY A PLASTIC THAT WAS
IN MUCH LESSER DEMAND- AND AS
IN PAST YEARS. AND SO I THINK
IT IN IN IN AS I SAID WAS A
STICKY WICKET BECAUSE IT REALLY
GETS YOU ON THAT QUESTION ABOUT
HOW WE RECYCLE AND HOW WEEKS
ALEXIS MATERIALS AND WHETHER OR
NOT WE MAKES LESS THAN THEY ARE
ULTIMATELY RECYCLABLE AND- AND
UNFORTUNATELY OUR CURRENT
WEBSITE SYSTEM. I'M RESULT IN A
LOT OF THOSE PLASTICS NOT AND
NOT ABLE TO BE RECYCLED AND SO
YOU'VE HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
WITH THIS PLAN IS THAT WE NEED
TO BE WORKING WITH ARMOR AND
THE REST OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE GET
THOSE PROSPECTS BACK IN A WAY
THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT
THAT'S RECYCLABLE. AND THEY
STERN FORMS I WE GET THEM TO
THE PLACE AND THERE WERE I'M
SOME OF OUR LARGER PRODUCERS AS
WELL AS OUR SMALLER PRODUCERS
THAT USE A SERVER FARMS ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE THOSE PRODUCTS RECYCLED
THEMSELVES AND SO. IT IS AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY AND SPEND RECYCLING
INDUSTRY AND WORKS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE AT AGAIN THAT
THAT NEVER ENDING LIFE OF A
PARTICULAR PRODUCT. AND WE NEED
TO GET THERE WITH THAT WITH THE
CLAM SHELLS AND SOME OF THESE
OTHER CONSUMER PRODUCTS IN A
WAY THAT WE CAN INCREASE THE.
THE AMOUNT OF STUFF THAT WE
HAVE. WHY I APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MENTION SINCE I'M AT THE-%
HERE. I'M SO I HAVE ONE MORE
AND LET'S SEE WHERE THAT ONE
GOES AND- SO ACT CARRY CYCLE- I
JUST CURIOUS OF WHAT WHAT'S
YOUR PLANS BECAUSE WE ARE GOING
TO NEED A PLAN MOVING FORWARD
AND IT'S GOING TO IT. AT A BE
INTERESTED IN IT AND YOU MAY
NOT HAVE IT DEVELOPED OR WHAT
YOUR THOUGHT PROCESSES BUT YOU
CAN AT LEAST GIVE ME AN IDEA
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH IT. THE
INTO LIFE PER SE OF- PEAVEY
PANELS AND BATTERIES FOR YOU
KNOW ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
ENERGY STORAGE- I KNOW IN IN
BORON IN MY DISTRICT THERE AT
PRODUCING LITHIUM FOR LITHIUM
BATTERY SO WE HAVE A LONGER
STORES HELP MEET RENEWABLE
GOALS. AND WE ALSO HAVE AGAIN I
KNOW THIS COMMITTEES PRIOR TO
HEARING ABOUT IT EVERYBODY IS
53% OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE.
LARGE SCALE SOLAR AND NOT JUST
ROOF TOP SOLAR BUT LARGE SCALE
SOLAR AND- SO AS I MEAN I THINK
THE PLANT IT'S GOING IN NOW IS
FIVE TIMES THE SIZE OF
DISNEYLAND. WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE NEED TO BUT WHERE DO THESE
THINGS GO AFTER THEIR LIFE IS
AND EXHAUSTED HEARING WE'VE
USED IT FOR. RENEWABLE ENERGY I.
MEAN WHAT'S YOUR PLAN FOR THAT.
SENATE AND IS. SEXY QUESTION WE
ARE PART OF AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
VERY SPECIFICALLY ON THIS ISSUE
ON BOTH BATTERIES AND TV PANELS
BECAUSE THAT IS A HUGE
QUESTIONS WE KNOW. THESE AREN'T
SIMPLY PIECES OF PLASTIC THESE
ARE VERY COMPLICATED. AND
MATERIALS WITH INTEGRATED AND
METALS CENTER AND I'M THAT HAVE
HOPEFULLY ADDITIONAL LIFE TO
GIVE AND BUT IF THEY'RE
RECYCLING PROCESS WILL BE. VERY
VERY COMPLICATED AND IT'S FUNNY
THAT YOU BRING UP THIS EXAMPLE
BECAUSE- I HAVE MY VERY FIRST
THOUGHTS AROUND A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY. HE MET BECAUSE I'M
SENATOR MONEY AUTHORED A BILL
ON THIS SUBJECT MANY YEARS AGO.
I'M SPECIFICALLY SAYING WE'RE
PUTTING ALL THESE TV PANELS OUT
IN THE WORLD WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO. DO WITH THAT HE SAID THAT'S
A REALLY GOOD QUESTION SENATOR
WE SHOULD BE DSIGNING OUR
PRODUCTS. DO YOU HAVE A SECOND
LIFE TEN AND NEVER ENDING LIKE
WE SHOULD BE DESIGNING IT WHICH
I UNDERSTAND WHERE OUR PRODUCTS
ARE GOING AT THE END OF THEIR
LIFE. AND WHAT THEIR NEXT LIFE
LOOKS LIKE. I'M AS WE ARE
DESIGNING ON NOT AT THE BACK
AND WE WERE TRYING TO FIGURE IT
OUT AND SERVE. THIS IS A HUGE
QUESTION RIGHT NOW IS MANY OF
OUR PREMIUM CHANNELS ARE COMING
TO THE END OF THEIR LIFE. I'M
THEIR FIRST LIFE. AND THAT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION SPECIFICALLY ON- ON
THIS BIG HUGE QUESTIONS SO I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE SPENT
MANY. OKAY TO COME UP WITH AN
ANSWER BUT I THINK THE LITHIUM
I BATTERY IS THE NEXT. THE NEXT
VERSION OF THAT AND SO WE NEED
TO BE WORKING WITH ARE.
MANUFACTURERS ON LOOKING AT
THIS AND BEFORE THEY BUT THOSE
BATTERIES OUTLINES CARS NOW ON
THE ROAD. AND WHAT ARE WE GONNA
DO. I THINK YOU AND SOME OF
THIS IS MY FEAR SO MY FEAR IS
THAT. AS WE GO FORWARD FOR
GREEN RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
TECHNOLOGY. AND AT THE SPEED OF
LIGHT REALLY AT THE SPEED OF
LIGHT OR JUST ABOUT. AND
INNOVATION IS HAPPENING
SPECIFICALLY IN MY DISTRICT
LITHIUM BATTERIES I MEAN
THEY'VE BEEN MINING IN BORON
FOR. DECADES RIGHT AND THE AND
NEVER EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT USING
THE BY PRODUCT WITH HIM UNTIL
THIS CAME UP AND NOW THEY'VE-
INVESTED YOU KNOW BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN A RESEARCH FACILITY
THAT PROVIDES LITHIUM BATTERIES
TO ALLOW YOU GUYS TO DO STORAGE
AND- YOU KNOW CREATE. AND MORE
RENEWABLE ENERGY. EV BUT
THERE'S NOT A PATH TO WHERE
THESE BATTERIES GOING TO GO-
THE SAME WITH THE SOLAR PANELS-
MY FURIOUS AND- THAT FOR THE
SAME REASONS THAT. ARE
WARRANTED BECAUSE OF OTHER
ISSUES THAT ARE GOING ON
CURRENTLY IN THE STATE WITH
THEM. MY DISTRICT PRODUCING
THIS POWER IS THAT. IT JUST
LIKE THIS BILL WILL GO BACK TO
THE PRODUCER RIGHT BACK TO THE
MANUFACTURER WELL- I DON'T
THINK THAT'S A LITTLE FAIR I
DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT. I MEAN IS THERE
A PUT IT DO YOU THINK THAT IT
WOULD JUST BE PUSHED BACK TOOK
ARMS AND SAY IT IS GONNA BE
PUSHED BACK TO KERN COUNTY IN
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE
OF IT. AND WITH NO HAVE YOU
KNOW. NO PLAN FROM THE STATE.
OTHER THAN TO MANDATE IS TO
TAKE CARE OF IT. WELL SENATOR I
EIGHT EIGHT AND I'M NOT GOING
TO SEE YOU- FORECAST WHAT I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION OF HOW THE STATE IS
GOING TO HANDLE THIS. BUT LIKE
I SAID YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST
DECADE WE'VE LOOKED AT THESE
COMPLICATED ISSUES IN THIS
COMPLICATED MATERIALS AND HAD
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS. WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS AS I'M A LECTURE
CRITICAL BATTERIES AND AS SOME
OF THE YOU KNOW THAT LARGE
BANERJEE BATTERY ENERGY STORAGE
MANUFACTURERS. AND ASKED THEM
THIS QUESTION ASK THEM AS THEY
WERE DESIGNING THEIR PRODUCTS
HOW THEY INTEND TO REALLY
EITHER EXTEND THE LIFE OR DEAL
WITH. WITH THE END OF LIFE AND
THEY'VE BEEN VERY MUCH AT THE
TABLE AND PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION SO. MY GRANT HIM
IS THAT HE THAT I THAT NO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE IN A POSITION
WHERE WE'RE AT THE END OF LIFE
AND RASPING WE HAVE A HAS. A
STACK OF CRTS I ALWAYS USE THIS
YEAR TO USE AS MY EXAMPLE SO
THAT THE TELEVISIONS THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO. WHERE TO
SEND THEM I DON'T THINK THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AGAIN AND- YOU
KNOW I THINK WE LEARNED OUR
LESSONS FROM. FROM THE E. WASTE
THAT SITUATION AND WE LEARNED
OUR LESSON FROM THE EXCITED
SITUATION AS A STATE WE'RE
WORKING REALLY HARD IN
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
WORKING REALLY HARD. TO NOT END
UP IN A SITUATION WHERE WE
WHERE WE HAVE HAVE. A LITERAL
STOCKPILE OF WASTE AND ACTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ANSWERING ALL MY QUESTIONS
AGAIN I'M SORRY ABOUT THE
MEETING YESTERDAY. I LOOKS
FORWARD AND TO YOU ASSUMING
THIS POSITION AND I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO AND WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE FUTURE ON THIS ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY. BECAUSE OF THE
DIRECTION THAT KERN IS GOING ON
RENEWABLES THANK YOU MA'AM. YOU
AS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR AND I COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE WHAT A CRAZY
SCHEDULE YOU ALL HAD THE SPEAKS
OF THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND YOUR TIMES. THANK
YOU. KERR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND WAGNER IT IS VERY GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME YESTERDAY OR
MONDAY I CAN'T EVEN I NEVER
REMEMBER THE DAYS- TO TALK TO
ME ABOUT YOUR ROLE AND CAL
RECYCLED. YOU KNOW I'M JUST
GONNA SAY- RIGHT NOW THAT I
THINK YOU ARE IMMENSELY.
QUALIFIED FOR THIS JOB- YOUR
KNOWLEDGE BASE IS VERY DEEP ON
THE ISSUES- THAT FALL UNDER CAL
RECYCLE. AND AS YOU HAVE-
SHARED IN YOUR RESPONSES TO THE
QUESTIONS ASKED BY MINUTE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE DIESS.
CALORIE CYCLE DOES A LOT- IT IS
A COMBINATION OF SORT OF THE
FUNCTIONAL IMPLEMENTATION. OF
PRACTICES AND POLICIES- I THINK
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO HELP
PROTECT. AND HEAL THE EARTH AND
ENCOURAGE GREATER PARTICIPATION
FROM CALIFORNIANS IN THAT. AND
THEN IT'S EDUCATION- TO YOUR
PARTNERS- CUSTOMERS CUSTOMERS
BEING INDIVIDUALS BEING CITIES
OTHER JURISDICTIONS. ABOUT WHAT
YOU GET FOR WHAT YOU DO AND THE
WHAT YOU DO IS THE RECYCLING OF
THE COMPOSTING- BY THE REUSING
AND HOPEFULLY WHAT YOU GET- IS
CLEANER LAND CLEANER AIR
CLEANER WATER. ETCETERA BOTH OF
THOSE ELEMENTS OF THE WORK
INVOLVES CUSTOMER SERVICE- AND
HOW YOU'RE RESPONDING TO THE
CUSTOMER'S I'M IN SO I KNOW WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS- UP IN OUR
DISCUSSION ON MONDAY SO IT
WOULD BE GREAT. JUST TO KIND
OF- SHARE SOME OF THOSE
RESPONSES AGAIN. THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE WHICH I SHARED WITH
YOU- FROM THE SERIOUS CAREER
REALLY ABOUT- A VERY SMALL CITY
I'M TRYING TO WORK THROUGH I
THINK THE CHALLENGES OF
IMPLEMENTATION WITHIN AN
ORGANICS PROGRAM- AND PROBABLY
LOOKING TO CAL RECYCLE AS A
PARTNER- AND- ACCORDING TO THE
ARTICLE IN SOME OF THE FOLKS
YOU KNOW FELT KIND OF
UNDERMINED. BY THE DEPARTMENT
AND FIGURED AND SEEMED IT
SEEMED AS IF THE DEPARTMENT WAS
WORKING AGAINST THEM RATHER
THAN TRYING TO WORK WITH THEM-
AND MANY OF THESE POLICIES I'M
SURE CAN BE OVERWHELMING
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL CITIES OR
CITIES THAT DON'T SEEM LIKE
THEY AREAMPLY RESOURCE- TO.
ADDRESS YOU KNOW RECYCLING
MARKETS NEW PROGRAMS LIKE
CETERA. AND THEN OF COURSE I
SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES YOU KNOW- THAT EVEN
MY OFFICES HAD WITH GETTING
SOME TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM-
CAL RECYCLE SO JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU CAN SPEAK TO YOUR
PLAN- AS ITS NEW LEADER- ON HOW
YOU LEAD A DIFFERENT APPROACH
TO CUSTOMER SERVICE- BECAUSE AS
YOU HAVE SHARED IN. WITH ME
LISTENING TO YOU- IT'S THIS IS
VERY EXTENSIVE WORK ARM IN
THERE A LOT OF PARTICULARS- AND
FOR THE AVERAGE PERSON IN
PROBABLY ONCE AGAIN FOR THE
SMALL CITY- THE PARTNERSHIP AND
THE CUSTOMER SERVICE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO MAKING
SURE THAT YOU WILL EVENTUALLY
HAVE SUCCESSFUL DATA TO REPORT
OUT. WE SENATOR I SO APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION IS SOMETHING
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT ON MONDAY AND SOMETHING
THAT I AM VERY SENSITIVE TO AND
AGAIN COMING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND AS AS AS AS A
STAFFER I REALLY DO LOOK AND AT
AND HOW WE SERVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS TRULY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATUREAND THROUGH
CONSTITUENTS AND THAT IS OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AND LOCAL OR
OTHERWISE AND INDIVIDUAL
CONSTITUENTS AND HOW DO WE
SERVE. AND THROUGH EDUCATION
AND SERVICES SO THAT WE ARE ALL
SUCCESSFUL AND SERRA AND IT IT
HAS AND YOU KNOW YOU IN DALLAS
HOUSING I DID CHECK INTO THE
SITUATION INCINERATES JUST TO
LET YOU KNOW AND IT WAS AN
UNFORTUNATE MISCOMMUNICATION OF
WHERE OUR STAFF WAS TRYING. TO
BE EXTRA COMMUNICATIVE. IT'S
AND UP IN A MISSED ME. I'M THAT
SENSE BEEN REMEDY THANK. AND
BUT IT REALLY AS YOU POINTED
OUT IS SOMETHING THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT REALLY CAN CAN WORK
ON IT THAT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO WORK
ON IS OUR COMMUNICATION TOOLS
HOW WE MEET WITH THE
LEGISLATURE HOW WE COMMUNICATE
WITH AT WITH OUR- CONSTITUENTS
AND OUR OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AND- AND I HAVE A TOP NOTCH
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR WHO IS.
WORKING ON AN EDUCATIONAL
CAMPAIGN RIGHT NOW WHO IS
WORKING WITH ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS ON HOW WE COMMUNICATE
AND- IS REALLY BECOMING MORE
AND OUR COMMUNICATIONS OFFICE
OR OFFICE OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS. IS
BECOMING MORE INTEGRAL TO
WORKING WITH OUR OUR EACH OF
OUR PROGRAMS AND ON HOW WE
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE- EIGHT
YEAR. HI I CAN HAVE ALL OF THE
KNOWLEDGE IN THE WORLD AND
ABOUT HOW TO DO SOMETHING BUT
IF I CAN'T COMMUNICATE AND I'M
NOT GOING TO SUCCESSFULLY. GET
HI YEAH- ANYBODY THERE SO I'M
IT IS SOMETHING WE ARE WORKING
ON AND INTERNALLY EXTERNALLY
AND AS THIS DEPARTMENT.
CONTINUES TO GROW AND EVOLVE
AND THE KIND OF REALLY AND A
LARGER SIZED APARTMENT IT IS A
GROWING PAIN THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING AND- AGAIN I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR AND FOR THE
FOLLOW UP- YOU TALKED IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENTS ABOUT- THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND I THINK
YOU REFERENCED IT IN SOME OF
THE RESPONSES YOU GAVE TO-SOME
QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP IN.
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT
ESPECIALLY IN RELATIONSHIP TO
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE URBAN OUT
POOR- AND DIVERSE- YOU KNOW WE-
AND I'M SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE SOUTHERN PART OF MY
DISTRICT. I LIKE TO SAY WE DO A
LOT OF RECYCLING YOU KNOW POOR
FOLKS WERE IN THE RECYCLING
GAME LONG BEFORE IT WAS- YOU
KNOW TRENDY- AND YOU ACTUALLY
TALKED ABOUT THAT YOURSELF
WITH- THEIR RECENT THE RE USE
OF TEXTILES. SO WE ARE YOU KNOW
COLLECTING CANS WE ARE
RECYCLING- BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
WHEN THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND. GREEN INVESTMENT IN
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE. THOSE
DOLLARS AND THOSE COMMITMENTS
GO TO OTHER PLACES AND MAYBE
IT'S BECAUSE THERE'S MORE OPEN
SPACE SEARCHING FOR LAND I
DON'T KNOW WHY MAYBE IT'S
BECAUSE FOLKS DON'T WANT TO.
PUT THAT KIND OF INVESTMENT IN
AN URBAN CENTER. BUT I BELIEVE
THAT IT'S REALLY HARD TO CREATE
BUY IN FROM PEOPLE WHEN YOU
OVERLOOK THEM- WHEN YOU'RE
HAVING DISCUSSIONS AROUND
INVESTMENT. AND SO. SINCE WE DO
HAVE SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY SINCE WE ALSO DO HAVE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT IT SEEMS LIKE IT
MAKES SENSE TO KIND OF TALK
ABOUT HOW YOU CONVERGE- OF
THOSE TWO ISSUES. AT AND CREATE
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO AB
SUSPEND SUSTAINABLE. BUT ALSO
BE- YOU KNOW ECONOMICALLY
ADVANTAGEOUS SO. YEAH I'D- LIKE
TO GET YOU KNOW A I'D LOVE TO
GET A COMMITMENT FROM YOU TO
COMMON TORE MY DISTRICT WITH
ME- I HAVE SO MANY IDEAS ABOUT
ORGANICS AND COMPOSTING
INSIGHTS AND OPPORTUNITIES YOU
AND I TALKED A LOT ABOUT. SORT
OF TEXTILES AND HOW WE CAN PLAY
IN A DEEPER RLE IN THAT YOU
KNOW I'M ACTUALLY A FAN OF-
STOPPING ALL PRODUCTION FOR A
MINUTE SO THAT WE CAN CURB OUR
WASTE IN OUR CONSUMPTION. I
KNOW THAT'S KIND OF HEAVY FOR
SOME. BUT I WOULD LOVE TO GET A
COMMITMENT FOR ME TO COME TO
THE DISTRICT AND ALSO WOULD
LOVE TO GET SOME KIND OF
COMMITMENT FROM SOMEONE ABOUT.
YOU KNOW REMINDING FOLKS ABOUT
SOUTH LA AND PLACES ACROSS THE
STATE LIKE SOUTH LA THAT
DESERVE YOU KNOW- THIS KIND OF.
INVESTMENT AND COMMITMENT
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE THERE
THE JOBS ARE THERE THE WILL IS
THERE. BUT NO ONE ACTUALLY
SEEMS TO CONSIDER THEM. AND A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY IS AS IS AS
MUCH ABOUT. FROM A TANAMI. YOU
KNOW IN THE CREATION OF CAREERS
AND JOBS- AND EMANCIPATION FROM
CERTAIN SYSTEMS AND LESS ABOUT
CHARITY- AND IT ALSO MOVES US
FORWARD WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAL
AND PROTECT MOTHER EARTH SO CAN
YOU LITTLE TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW MAYBE THERE CAN BE A
SHIFT- IN- PERCEPTION ABOUT
PLACES LIKE SOUTH LA AND OUR
ROLE IN THIS- CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WOULD LOVE TO COME
IN FOR YOUR DISTRICT I THINK
THAT WOULD BE FANTASTIC AND-
AND WOULD LIKE TO BRING A TEAM
OF PEOPLE DOWN TO SORRY YOUR
DISTRICT AND BECAUSE YOU ARE
HITTING ON A POINT THAT IS NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART- I SPENT A
LOT OF TIME. WELL AND WORKING
AND FOR THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
OUT WORKING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS YOU KNOW WITH HI
ON I'M- THE ECCENTRICITY- AND
VERNON. AND SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME THINKING ABOUT THE HISTORY
OF THAT FACILITY AND WHAT IT.
HAS DONE TO THAT COMMUNITY AND
THAT. SORT OF THE DICHOTOMY OF
ITS HISTORY RIGHT BECAUSE IT
PROVIDED. A CAREER PATH AND
SOME REALLY GOOD JOBS TO PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME- SALUTING THEIR ERROR
AND THEY'RE WATER AND- AND
REALLY- DOES READING THAT
COMMUNITY AND SO. I'M I SPENT
ON MANAGEMENT FOR THE LAST
DECADE THINKING ABOUT WILL. BE
INVESTING IN COMPANIES IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T DO THAT.
THAT BRING THE GOOD JOBS. AND
BRING CAREER OPPORTUNITIES AND
LONGEVITY. AND DO IT IN A WAY-
THAT REALLY ADDS FUELS THAT
COMMUNITY AND ISN'T THAT WHERE
WHEN YOU. HAVE STATE PROGRAMS
AND INVEST IN BUSINESS ISN'T
THAT THE KIND OF BUSINESS THAT
WE SHOULD BE INVESTING IN. AND
ADDS THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY IS
INNOCENT MASON CITY. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY VERY SPECIFICALLY
TO HAVE THAT. CONVERSATION WHO
ARE THE COMPANIES WHO WANT TO
INVEST. IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL BENEFIT FROM THE JOBS THAT
WILL BENEFIT FROM THOSE CAREER
PASSED. ON AND THAT ARE GOING
TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
POLLUTE OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
CREATE NEW PUBLIC HOUSE RESTS.
SO THIS IS VERY SPECIFICALLY
AGAIN. WHY I WAS SO EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY THIS IS
SOMETHING VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO
THE GOVERNOR'S ART THIS IS
SOMETHING WE TALKED ABOUT A
LOT. AND OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS. AS BUILDING THE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY AND WHY WE'RE DOING IT
AND THIS IS- VERY PURPOSEFULLY
WHY WE'RE DOING IT HOW DO WE
INVEST. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT. ARE ECONOMICALLY
UNDERSERVED AND BUILD
SOMETHING. AND WHAT I THINK
WOULD BE BEAUTIFUL. THANK YOU
THAT- AND THE ARE THANK YOU
VERY EXCITED THIS I CAN TELL
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHY IT SHOWS
THAT YOU ARE. QUALIFIED FOR
THIS POSITION. IT IS NOT
RELATED TO CURRENT CYCLE BUT
I'LL JUST SURE THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE IN THE PAPER EARLIER
THIS WEEK THAT TALKED ABOUT
WIND TURBINES- AND IT'S A GREAT
CAREER OPPORTUNITY FOR ROCK
CLIMBERS. FOLKS THAT DON'T
REALLY HAVE YOU KNOW COLLEGE
DEGREES- BUT THIS SKILL- HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY USEFUL FOR THEM
GOING UP AND MAKING REPAIRS AND
MAKING SIX FIGURE SALARIES AND
BEING ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR FAMILIES. NOW NONE OF
THAT IS HAPPENING IN SOUTH LA-
AND I THINK AS WE BEGIN TO TALK
ABOUT DIFFERENT WAYS TO USE AND
CONSERVE- AND REUSE ENERGY AS
WE TALK ABOUT DIFFERENT KINDS
OF WAYS TO REUSE AND RECYCLE.
THE MATERIALS THAT WE HAVE- IT
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
EMPLOY. FOLKS IN WHO WE CAN
EMPLOY IN THE SKILLS THE
DIFFERENT KIND OF SKILLS THAT
THEY MAY HAVE. ON THAT WILL
PROVE ADVANTAGEOUS TO US MAKING
THE KINDS OF GOALS- THAT I
THINK ARE PRESCRIBED UNDER-
YOUR MANDATE WITH CAL RECYCLE
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGREE
HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN SENIOR DISTRICT.
THANK YOU SENATOR COM LAGER-
WELL I HINK AGAIN ALWAYS GO IN
LAST- THE QUESTION TO ASK I
APPRECIATE SENATOR LARGE
QUESTIONS ABOUT- CERTAINLY
TIRES AT THE BORDER AND- I
REMEMBER HIM VISITING WHEN. I
WAS THERE AND- THE ISSUE HAS
BEEN BEEN AN ISSUE FOR MANY
YEARS AND I APPRECIATE OUR
FORMER SENATOR DO CHENEY TRYING
TO HAVE LEGISLATION AND THEN WE
FOLLOWED UP WITH LEGISLATION TO
TRY TO. FREE SOME RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF CROSS
BORDER SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT ISSUE UP- OF THE
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED THE
ONE THING THAT- AND BY THE WAY
WHEN YOU'RE IN LA YOU CAN DRIVE
ON DOWN IT SOUGHT. ONLY A
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILES BUT IT
MAY TAKE A LITTLE LONGER THAN.
THAN TWO HOURS TO GET THERE. ON
TRAFFIC BUT SAN DIEGO COME
VISIT US WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
YOU AS WELL. CHECK OUT OUR
DISTRICT THE ONLY THING I WANT
TO BRING UP- IS REALLY VERY
MUCH ALSO A RESPONSE I'M
GETTING FROM ONE COMMUNITY IN
MY DISTRICT AND I HAPPENED TO
BE THERE THIS WEEKEND FOR THE
FOURTH OF JULY- SOME FOURTH OF
JULY ACTIVITIES SO I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO TELL THEM THAT I
BROUGHT THIS TO YOUR ATTENTION
DIRECTLY. AND THAT IS-
BASICALLY AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTION QUESTION AND- YOU KNOW
THE LAW IS PRETTY CLEAR- ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT BUT- ODD THAT ROUTE
REQUIRES RETAILERS TO TAKE BACK
RECYCLABLES WHERE THERE'S NO
CONVENIENCE CENTER. AND A HORSE
I THAT'S NOT HAPPENING AND
THERE ARE. PRETTY SPECIFIC
FUNDS WHICH I'M NOT ADVOCATING
FOR BECAUSE I WOULD RATHER HAVE
THE SOLUTION. TO THE PROBLEM
BUT- I WILL BE IN RANCHO
BERNARDO THIS WEEKEND AND I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO TELL THEM.
THE CLOSEST CENTER- FRANKLY IS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MINUTES AWAY
AND NO RETAILERS ARE ACCEPTING
RECYCLABLES- SO. I KNOW THAT
THERE MAY BE OUR- SOME
PRACTICAL ISSUES- BUT I JUST
WANTED TO BRING THAT TO YOUR
ATTENTION. AND HAPPENS HAVING
SAID THAT MY ONE ISSUE MY ONE
CONCERN ALTHOUGH LET ME BE
CLEAR OFF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
BROUGHT UP A NUMBER OF ISSUES-
THAT I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WATCH AND MONITOR
BUT I HAVEN'T SAID THOSE THOSE
FEW THINGS AND ADDING MY
SUPPORT OF COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE. I CAN'T THINK OF
ANYONE MORE ENTHUSIASTIC- TO
TAKE ON THIS ROLE- CERTAINLY
YOUR YOUR TIME IN THE SENATE
AND THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE
AS A CONSULTANT AND STAFF
AROUND THESE CRITICAL ISSUES
AND THEN OF COURSE YOUR WORK IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
HORSESHOE- ARE REALLY- IT'S NO
SURPRISE. THAT THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTED YOU TO THIS POSITION
SO YOU AGAIN YOUR ENTHUSIASM
YOUR LOVE OF THE ISSUES I HOPE
THAT- KEEPS YOU UP AND GOING-
DESPITE SOME OF THE BIG ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE AHEAD OF US AS WE
TRY TO. ADDRESS YOU KNOW HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS IN LIGHT
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES THE
ENVIRONMENT AND CHALLENGES SO-
WITH THAT I CERTAINLY SUPPORT-
THIS CONFIRMATION. AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE TO HELP US ON SO MANY
ISSUES BEFORE YOU WERE
APPOINTED TO THIS. POSITION I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. EYE THAT
MAY BE HERE TO WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND I WANT TO ASK
FOLKS AS THEY APPROACH- THAT
THE DICE TO SPEAK THAT IT BUT
IT BE ONE PERSON AT A TIME. LET
THE PERSON SIT DOWN AND THEN
SECOND PERSON COME ON UP WE ARE
STILL RECOGNIZING- DISTANCE. I
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC AND LET ME GO AHEAD
AND- T. UP THE PHONE NUMBER FOR
THOSE. WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA
TELECONFERENCE I'M GOING TO
GIVE THE NUMBER AGAIN. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
TWO ONE FIVE. THAT ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT TWO
NINE ONE AND WITH THAT LET ME
WELCOME OUR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE- MISTER TAYLOR COME ON
FORWARD AND- GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OKAY IS IT ON LET ME
LET ME MAKE SURE THAT IT IS SO
THAT WE CAN HEAR YOU I WANT TO
A- I WANT THE APPOINTEE TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU ALSO. GO AHEAD
LET'S TRY AGAIN MADAM CHAIR A
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
NIAGARA BOTTLING AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
RACHEL WAGNER- WE'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH HER
IN HER.TIME IN THE SENATE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND NOW
IS DIRECTOR OF CALORIE CYCLE. I
THINK AS YOU AND- CENTER COM
LONGER NOTED EARLIER SHE BRINGS
TREMENDOUS EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERTISE TO THIS POSITION. WE
FOUND HER TO BE- OPEN TO
HEARING ALL SIDES BEFORE SHE
RENDERS A DECISION- AND SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR
CONFIRMATION MADAM PROTON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESSPLEASE AS SOON AS WE
CLAR THE- DICE THANK YOU
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE ANTHONY WILLIAMS I AM
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF.
AS A- I GUESS MAYBE THE BRAG
ABOUT- RACHEL WHO- I HAVE KNOWN
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY WELL I
SHOULD SAY MORE YEARS THAN WE
NEED OR WHAT EITHER ONE OF US
WANT TO ADMIT- BUT SHE TAUGHT
ME ABOUT HAZARDOUS WASTE MANY
YEARS AGO AS STAFF WHEN WE WERE
WORKING ON LEGISLATION TOGETHER
AND- I HAVE WATCHED HER. CAREER
AND HER WORK WITH HER
PROFESSIONALLY AND HAD THE
GREAT HONOR OF HAVING HER JOIN-
OUR TEAM IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WHEN WE FIRST CAME IN
THE OFFICE- I CAN LIKE HAS
ALREADY BEEN SAID BY SO MANY-
CAN ALSO- JUST SAY THAT THERE'S
NO BETTER PERSON FOR THIS FOR
THIS ROLE AT THIS TIME AND I'M
X. X. LIKE EXTREMELY PROUD OF
HER. I CAME ALL THE WAY TO
HUNTINGTON BEACH TO BE HERE IN
PERSON TO GIVE MY SUPPORT TO
HER CONFIRMATION I'D STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH I THANK YOU MISTER
WILLIAMS I WAS GOING TO COMMENT
TO US- IT. TO MISS WAGNER YOU
OBVIOUSLY TRAVELED- TO MAKE
THIS PRESENTATION AND HE COULD
HAVE DONE IT BY TELECONFERENCE
SO OBVIOUSLY- THAT MAKES ITS
OWN STATEMENT SO THANK YOU.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS HEIDI SANBORN I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL. I ALSO HAVE BEEN IN
THIS INDUSTRY THIRTY ONE YEARS
I SERVED AS ADVISER TO THE
CHAIR OF THE WASTE MANAGEMENT
BOARD LINDA MOULTON PATTERSON
I'VE BEEN A CONSULTANT AND AN
ADVOCATE AND AN ANZAC WE
ADVOCATE FOR CIRCULAR ECONOMY
SO FINALLY THINGS ARE COMING
AROUND TO WHERE WE HOPE THAT
THEY WOULD BE. I ALSO SERVICE
CHAIR OF THE STATE MY
COMMISSION ON RECYCLING MARKETS
IN CURBSIDE RECYCLING AND I'M
NOT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMISSION TODAY BUT JUST TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT I ALSO SERVE
IN THAT ROLE- I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A BETTER PERSON IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THIS
POSITION. I'VE WORKED WITH- MS
WAGNER FOR MANY MANY YEARS ON
BILLS FROM PHARMACEUTICALS IF
YOU ARE TO- BATTERY. AND A PER.
AND SHE'S ALWAYS BEEN IN EVERY
ROLE SHE'S HAD. VERY THOUGHTFUL
VERY CARING AND VERY SMART AND
SHE CAN PICK UP VERY QUICKLY ON
VERY COMPLICATED ISSUES. TO
HAVE FIVE I USED TO WORK AT
WHEN THE BOARD WAS A WASTE
BOARD. NOW WE HAVE ONE PERSON
AT THE TOP OF A VERY
COMPLICATED. AGENCY IT'S
IMPERATIVE IT BE SOMEBODY
THAT'S GOT HISTORY AND THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE LAW AND OF THE
SITUATIONS AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AT HAND. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
REALLY ASK YOU TO CONFIRM HER-
AND JUST WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT TESTIMONY. NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT MY NAME IS JASON
SCHMELZER AND I'M HERE- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF MISS WAGNER
AND I ALSO LIKE TO MAKE- ONE
COMMENT JUST AS AN ADVOCATE
THAT'S BEEN DOING THIS FOR SOME
PERIOD OF TIME I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE
RACHEL OR VARIOUS CAPACITIES-
REPRESENTING CORORATIONS
PUBLIC ENTITIES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
I'VE BEEN TREATED THE SAME. IN
EVERY INSTANCE IT'S BEEN
WHIPPED FACT- GOT COMPASSION
OPENNESS TO IDEAS AND A FOCUS
ON PROBLEM SOLVING FOCUS ON THE
HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE ENVIRONMENT
OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT PERSON FOR
THE PERSON IN THIS OFFICE
COULDN'T MORE STRONGLY
SUPPORTER- FOR MY CLIENTS AND
PERSONALLY SO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND I THINK WE
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS COMING
FORWARD. WELCOME THANK YOU-
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND-
MULLIN PRETENDING MEMBERS
STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES AND ITS
FOURTEEN MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF- IS WAGONER'S
CONFIRMATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO REACH ITS MANY RECYCLING
GOALS THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH OKAY. OTHER
WITNESSES. OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE NOW. AND
I THINK WE GAVETHE NUMBER LET
ME DO IT ONE MORE TIME SINCE
WE'RE NOT PUT IT ON OUR SCREEN.
ARE NOT ABLE TO PUT IT ON OUR
SCREEN TODAY IT IS ON OUR
WEBSITE BUT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT TWO ONE
FIVE. THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
ZERO ZERO EIGHT TWO NINE ONE.
AND SO LET ME WELCOME- THE
MODERATOR AND AS THE MODERATOR
TEES UP WITNESSES WERE GOING TO
ASK THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK. YOU
PROVIDE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IF ANY AND POSITION ON THE
APPOINTMENT WE ARE TAKING
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT AT THIS
MOMENT. AND AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
OUR COURT REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY SO WE CAN
CAPTURE YOUR TESTIMONY. BOB
MODERATOR WELCOME. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHARE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND SUPPORT ME PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING
YOUR TELEPHONE. WE HAVE SEVERAL
MINES IN Q. WILL GO FIRST IN
LINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NUMBER TEN AND MILAN
REPRESENTING ALL OF THEM AND
ALSO JUST TESTIFYING AT THE BIG
FAN OF WAGNER. WAGNER NOT ONLY
HAS THE KNOWLEDGE AND VISION
BUT THE PASSION AND DEDICATION.
I ARE AND FUTURE. ABOUT WITH
MICHAEL ACADEMY AT THE VERY
POLLUTION AND- OINTMENT AND-
VERY. IN YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. APPLYING. NINETEEN ONE
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
PROGRAM AND MEMBER THIS IS
STEPHANIE MORE WHILE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF RECOLOGY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
ITS WAGONER- WE APPRECIATE ALL
OF HER WORK IN THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAD WITH HER OVER THE
YEARS IN HER VERY CAPACITIES
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HER AND
HER FUTURE ROLE AT CAL RECYCLE
WITNESS. LINE. TWELVE HELLO
CHAIRED MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE WE SUPPORT THE
APPOINTMENT OF RACHEL WAGNER TO
SERVE AS THE DIRECTOR HOW
THANKFUL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. FIND. TWENTY ONE.
OH SURE NUMBERS ON BEHALF OF
YOUR NORTHERN IRELAND SERVICES
TO SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT OF
RACIAL WAGNER CONSERVANCY
DIRECTOR CALL RECYCLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. FIND.
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
DENNIS I'LL BE ON A ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION CALIFORNIA AND THE
SUFFICIENT INDEPENDENT HAULERS
WHICH REPRESENTS ONE HUNDRED
GOT JUNK FRANCHISEES WE WORK
WITH- ANGEL IN MANY OF OUR-
PREVIOUS CAPACITIES AND ALSO
DIRECTOR. GERWIG SPRINGS
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE TO RUN
CALPERS CYCLE WE SUPPORT HER
NOMINATION. ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANICS RECYCLING AND IF THE
POP THE PACIFIC. ARE RENDERING
SUFFICIENT CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND
FEED WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
HER AND HER SISTER AGENCY
CALLED FOR DEPARTMENT OF OUTPUT
IN AGRICULTURE TO BETTER
RECOGNIZE THE ROLE OF
TRADITIONAL ORGANIC RECYCLERS.
THE BUILDING OF CIRCULAR
ECONOMY AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
THAT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HER. IN THE FUTURE IN THIS
CAPACITY THANK YOU. THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. FINE.
TWENTY TWO. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL AFTER
THE PRAYER IN THE KEIGHLEY ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES I
WANT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
SENATE CONFIRMED THE
APPOINTMENT RACHEL WAGNER AS
THE DIRECTOR OF CALORIE CYCLE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WE HAVE
KNOWN AND CLOSELY WORK WITH
MISS WAGNER CAPACITY AS
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT TO THE
STATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE W. LEGISLATIVE
SECRETARY TO GOVERNOR SOME AND
NOW IN HER CAPACITY AS THE
DIRECTOR OF CALORIE CYCLE. WE
HAVE ALWAYS KNOWN HER TO BE
OPEN THOUGHTFUL AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE RACHEL HAS EARNED
OUR RESPECT AND SUPPORT IT IS
WITH GREAT PLEASURE AND
CONFIDENCE THAT WE RECOMMEND TO
YOU AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE THAT YOU CONFIRM THE
APPOINTMENT OF RACHEL WAGNER.
IS THE DIRECTOR POWER CYCLE
THANK YOU. THE YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. FIND FOURTEEN ONE
FOUR. THE DALLAS A SECURE ON
BEHALF OF WASTE MANAGEMENT
CALLING IN SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF MISS RACHEL
WAGNER AS DIRECTOR OF CAL
RECYCLE WE ARE DEFINITELY
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER AND HER TEAM AND WE HAVE
FOUND HER AND HER TEAM
EXTREMELY ACCEPTABLE ANSWER
QUESTIONS WORK WITH THAT AND
ADDRESS YOU KNOW CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES ONCE AGAIN WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. FOR
CONFIRMATION TODAY. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE TWENTY TWO.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
WE'RE SUPER EXCITED TO SUPPORT
RACHEL'S CONFIRMATIONS- KNOWN
HER FOR MANY YEARS AND HAVE
ALWAYS FOUND HER TO BE-
PASSIONATE PRAGMATIST FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL SOLUTIONS I DO
HOPE THAT ALL THIS- LOVE IT
THIS CONFIRMATION HEARING
RACHEL WELL DESERVED LOVE- WILL
TRANSLATE INTO LEGISLATION THAT
GIVES HER DEPARTMENT GREATER
FLEXIBILITY AND GREATER ACCESS
TO THE REACH SURPLUS RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS- MISSION CRITICAL-
PROBLEM OF RECYCLING PROBLEM.
STATE BUT- STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU POINT TAKEN I NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO FURTHER
WITNESSES THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU- WE HAVE
FURTHER WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF. OKAY WITH THAT WE
WILL NOW COME- WELL I SHOULD
ADD THIS- MS WAGNER- YOU
PROBABLY WON'T BE SURPRISED
THAT OF COURSE I GET TEXT
MESSAGES DURING THE HEARING
FROM STAFF MEMBERS TO TELL ME
THEY WOULD SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
MISS WAGNER IF STAFF WERE
PERMITTED TO DO SO CHAU HI I'VE
NEVER GOTTEN A TEXT MESSAGE
LIKE THAT AT THE RULES
COMMITTEE- SHE'S RIFIC AND WORK
SO WELL WITH EVERYONE- SO SHE
WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA A BETTER
PLACE SO I'LL- LET YOU FIGURE
OUT WHICH STAFF MEMBERS MIGHT
BE SENDING THOSE TEXT MESSAGES
TO THEIR BOSS IN THE MIDDLE OF
CHAIRING A CITY. MADAM CHAIR
YOU THREADED THE NEEDLE QUITE
WELL BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT THAT ON
THE RECORD BUT WE DIDN'T CHANGE
THAT RULE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL YOU KNOW THESE ARE HARD
JOBS AND I THINK I I'VE BEEN
REALLY IMPRESSED BY THE FOLKS
WHO HAVE CALLED IN SUPPORT
HAVING SAID THAT NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO PEOPLE WHO MAY
BE HERE IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE
THEY ALSO- WILL WANT TO TESTIFY
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE NO ONE MOVING
FORWARD. SO I LET ME AGAIN TELL
YOU THAT FABULOUS TOLL FREE
NUMBER TO CALL AND MAKE YOUR
VOICE HEARD. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT TWO ONE FIVE
ACCESS CODE ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
TWO NINE ONE. MISTER MODERATOR
WELCOME BACK AND WILL YOU. T.
UP ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO STATE OPPOSITION
ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AT THIS TIME PLEASE. THANK YOU
MAN I'M SURE THERE ARE NO LINES
IN Q. AT THE TIME. OKAY LET ME
COME BACK INTO THE ROOM AND SEE
WHO IS GOING TO GIVE ME A
MOTION SENATOR. I'VE GOT A
WE WILL GO WITH THAT- MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH ALL RIGHT ROBERT
HI KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI
FLARED HI THERE I HATE I HATE I
CAN I CAN FIND I FIGURE. THIS
WAY HERE THAT WAS A UNANIMOUS
VOTE WE WILL MOVE YOUR
CONFIRMATION TO THE SENATE
FLOOR AND- WITH OUR
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
HERDSMEN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF WORDS I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
YEAR THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
RECESS AND WE WILL BE BACK TO
TAKE UP THE NEXT TWO
APPOINTMENTS AND I THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WILL BE
RIGHT BACK.
EDIT CALL THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE- BACK TO
ORDER AND- AS A REMINDER TO
FOLKS WHO MAY BE WATCHING WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE MULTIPLE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS TODAY SO- YOU WILL SEE
INDIVIDUALS- INDIVIDUAL
SENATORS COMING AND GOING.
ALTHOUGH HEALTH COMMITTEE JUST
ADJOURNED WE HAVE OTHER
COMMITTEES THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND- THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE ARE ALSO IN
SESSION AND TWO OF OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATE THERE SO. WITH
APOLOGIES TO OUR NEXT TWO
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR-
I AM GOING TO INTRODUCE- AND
WELCOME TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND THAT WOULD BE
SHERIFF INGRID BRAUN AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JOYCE E.
DUDLEY WHO IS THE CURRENT
CHAIR. OF POST I WANNA WELCOME
BOTH OF YOU AND- WE WILL TAKE
UP THE INTRODUCTIONS IN ORDER I
IN WHICH I JUST STATED SO WE
WILL START WITH- SHERIFF BRAUN.
LET YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF MAKE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THANK- AND THEN
GO RIGHT INTO YOUR COMMENTS
AND- THEN- WE WILL GO AHEAD- IT
TO WELCOME COMMISSIONER DUDLEY
AND ALLOW YOU TO DO THE SAME
AND- THEN WE'LL GET STARTED AND
ASKED MY COLLEAGUES TO DIRECT
THEIR QUESTIONS TO A SPECIFIC
COMMISSIONER. OR LET THEM KNOW
IF YOU WANT BOTH TO RESPOND.
WITH THAT- LET ME SAY WELCOME
TO SHERIFF BRAUN- AND PLEASE-
GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS AND
MEMBERS OF THE ROYAL COMMITTEE
RULES COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON
I HAVE A GREAT BROWN'S JEREMIAH
COUNTY FIRST I THINK MY HUSBAND
AND MY FAMILY FOR SUPPORTING ME
EACH DAY MY HUSBAND MIKE IS
RETIRED LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
WASHINGTON HOME I AM AT MY
OFFICE IN BRIDGEPORT. I KNOW MY
SISTER ERICA IS WATCHING
OAKLAND AND MY SISTER AND I
WATCHED YEAH- MY EIGHTY FIVE
YEAR OLD FATHER IT DOESN'T
WORKING ON THIS BUT I DOUBT
VERY MUCH THAT HE IS WATCHING
SEVEN CALIFORNIA. WATCHING. HIS
ONLINE IS NOT REALLY GET. I A
THIRTY YEAR. IN LINE. WHICH IS
MORE THAN HALF MY LIFE AS I
WILL TO FIFTY FOUR TOMORROW. I
AND MY SEVEN YEAR IS NOT CAN
YOU SHARE I RETIRED TO MY
COUNTY LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT TEN YEARS AGO AFTER
TWENTY ONE YEAR CAREER. WORK
ASSIGNMENTS IN PATROL JUVENILE
CRIMES INVESTIGATIONS INTERNAL
AFFAIRS. ADMINISTRATOR AS A
WATCH COMMANDER IN ASKING HER
COLLEAGUES THE TENANTS. I
RETIRED AS A LIEUTENANT. I'VE
ALSO WORKED AS A DEPUTY FOR THE
MARION COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
AND IS A RESERVE OFFICER FOR
THE MAMMOTH LAKES POLICE
DEPARTMENT- WHEN YOU SPOKE
AGENCY IN MARIN COUNTY. AND IT
IS THIS RARE COMBINATION OF
URBAN AND RURAL EXPERIENCE BOTH
TROLLING LEADERSHIP LEVELS THAT
MAKE ME UNIQUE ADDITIONS THE
COMMISSION. ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. AND
THAT COULD MY STATEMENT. WELL
THANK YOU FOR MUCH LET ME NEXT
WELCOME I'D DISTRICT ATTORNEY
JOYCE DUDLEY WHO IS THE CURRENT
SHARE OF POST SAY WELCOME AND-
INVITE YOU TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS. THANK YOU CENTER
ATKINS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. I THANK YOU ALL FOR
INVITING ME TO THIS
EXTRAORDINARY INTERVIEW. ARE BY
WAY THE NEXT ACTION OF ME I'M
GOING TO START WITH MY
PROFESSIONAL SIDE I'M IN MY
THIRD TERM AS DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR SANTA BARBARA COUNTY I'M
ALSO ON THE EXECUTIVE BOARD OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS AND THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION PROSECUTORS
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE
ADDITIONALLY I AM ON THE BOARD
OF HOSPICE. I HAVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY IN N. B.
D. WITH AN EMPHASIS ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION OUR SECOND
MASTERS IN EDUCATIONAL
ADMINISTRATION AND FINALLY I AM
A GRADUATE OF THE NIGHT LAW
SCHOOL. I AM THE GRANDDAUGHTER
OF A NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
HOMELESS IMMIGRANTS. I AM THE
DAUGHTER OF THE MOTHER WHO WENT
TO NIGHT SCHOOL FOR SEVENTEEN
YEARS BECAUSE ALL SHE COULD
AFFORD TO TAKE- WAS ONE CLASS
AT A TIME. AND UNTIL SHE
FINALLY GOT HER BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. AND I'M JUST A THE
REASON I'M SMILING IS WHEN I
GOT MY SECOND MASTER'S DEGREE
SHE AND I ACTUALLY HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WALKING ACROSS THE
STAGE TOGETHER- I WAS ALSO THE
WIFE OF A BRILLIANT HYDRO%
GEOLOGISTS. AND I SUSPECT MY
GRANDFATHER MOTHER AND HUSBAND-
IF THEY COULD WATCH FROM HEAVEN
ARE WATCHING TV. I AM PRESENTLY
THE MOTHER OF FOUR
EXTRAORDINARY MAN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ATTORNEY. AND
ENGINEER WHO JUST GRADUATED
BERKLEE A TEACHER AND A
FIREFIGHTER. ADDITIONALLY I AM
A GRANDMOTHER OF FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN. A FOUR YEAR OLD
DINOSAUR DEVOTES J. A SEVEN
YEAR OLD BELIEVER IN UNICORNS A
THREE YEAR OLD ROCK AND ROLL
SINGER AND A TWO YEAR OLD
RASPBERRY. YEAH AND FINALLY I
AM THE PROUD GRANDMOTHER TO
RESCUE DOGS. LONG BEFORE I WAS
A COMMISSIONER PROPOSED I WAS
INVOLVED WITH POST I WAS A
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT A
CURRICULUM CONSULTANT AND A
LONG TIME TRAINER. I'VE BEEN ON
PROPOSED COMMISSIONS OR OTHER
NOW AROUND SEVEN YEARS. AND
IT'S BEEN AN ABSOLUTE HONOR FOR
ME TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THAT
CAPACITY. I AM TRULY IN AWE THE
STAFF POST NOW MORE THAN EVER
BECAUSE OF THEIR- WORK THEY'VE
BEEN DOING AND THAT THE SUPERB
LEADERSHIP OF MANNY ALVAREZ.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS TIME AND I'M PREPARED
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET
ME GO AHEAD- THE SENATOR COME
WATER WOULD YOU LIKE TO START
US OFF THIS ROUND. SURE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WELL IT IS-
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN- CHAIR W.
WE HAD A COUPLE OF MOMENTS-
EARLIER THIS MORNING TO CHAT.
AND ALSO WITH YOU SHERIFF
BRAUN- GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME. I JUST HAVE A FEW-
QUESTIONS FOR ARE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- FOR THE BOTH OF YOU
AND I WILL MAKE SURE TO
DESIGNATE- TO WHOM THEY ARE
DIRECTED- FOUR MR LEE I REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOUR INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS AND YOUR EMPHASIS ON
FAMILY- AND HOW IMPORTANT THEY
ARE TO YOU AND AS YOU KNOW I
OFTEN I SIT ON PUBLICSAFETY
NOW AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND OFTEN. ALSO SORT
OF TALK ABOUT HAVE TALKED ABOUT
FAMILY- AND THEIR IMPORTANCE TO
ME WHEN DISCUSSING A LOT OF
CRIMINAL LEGAL REFORM BILLS-
BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES- FOLKS THAT
LOOK LIKE MY FAMILY ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE SUBJECT TO- VERY
SPECIFIC DISCUSSIONS AROUND
SAFETY- AB THREE NINETY TWO
COMES TO MIND SPECIFICALLY- BUT
THIS YEAR WE'VE ALSO BEEN
TALKING A LOT ABOUT THE
CERTIFICATION. AND I CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO STEP ON- MY
PROGRAMS THAT TOES IN ASKING
THIS QUESTION BUT WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS- BOTH OF
YOUR THOUGHTS- ON
DECERTIFICATION- AND- HOW. POST
IF THIS IS TO PASS- HOW POSTS
RELATIONSHIP- TO MAKING SURE
THAT- IT IS IMPLEMENTED IN A
WAY- THAT IS TRUE TO THE INTENT
AND THE REASON WHY I ASK- IS
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW MUCH W. R.
CHAIR OF THE HOST- AND SO
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT- BUT
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MAYBE NOT
EVERYONE ON THE COMMISSION HAS
THE SAME THOUGHTS. AROUND THE
CERTIFICATION- AND WHAT IT
pSTATE AND SHERIFF BRIAN AS
SOMEONE WHO IS AN ACTING
SHERIFF- WHO HAS TALKED ABOUT
QUESTIONS AROUND
STANDARDIZATION OF THIS- BUT
ALSO SOMEONE WHO WOULD IS ON.
WHO IS NOW ON POST- YOU KNOW
THESE KINDS OF PERSPECTIVES ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY WILL THEY WILL EFFORT THEY
WILL GREEN FOR FOLKS. HOW
SUCCESSFUL THESE THINGS
ACTUALLY BECOME- AND HOW THEY
ARE IMPLEMENTED IN A WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE VERY LONG QUESTION
I APOLOGIZE. FOR I WOULD LOVE
IF- CHAIR DUDLEY COULD GO FOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU- WELL FIRST
OF ALL WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
FAMILY YES THAT IS VERY MUCH MY
PASSION. AND MY- FIRST HUSBAND
IS LATINO AND AMERICAN INDIANS
AND I HAVE A DARK SKIN CHILD
AND MY SECOND HUSBAND WAS ANGLO
AND SO I HAVE A WHITISH SKIN
CHILD. AND I'VE LEARNED A WHOLE
LOT FROM LISTENING TO BOTH OF
THEM- BECAUSE I'M THEY TALKED
ABOUT DIFFERENT TREATMENT
THEY'VE RECEIVED AND I HAVE
EVERY REASON TO TRUST THAT IN
EVERY REASON TO FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY. IN TERMS OF NOT JUST
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT HEALTHCARE
EDUCATION EVERY OTHER COMPONENT
THAT MAKES YOUNG MEN GROW UP TO
BE WHO THEY ARE NOT WOMEN. IN
TERMS OF THE CERTIFICATION IT'S
ME LEGISLATION THAT INTERESTS
ME THE MOST RIGHT NOW. I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO BE A PART OF AN
ORGANIZATION THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE WHEN WE SAW MISSOURI
REALLY MISSPELLED LIKE I ALSO
SORRY AND WITH MY APOLOGIES.
SENATOR COM LAGER NEEDS TO GO
VOTE AND BUDGET HI THIS IS OUR
DILEMMA TODAY THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION SO I'M GOING
TO PUT A PAUSE ON IT AND WE
WILL COME BACK AS SENATOR
PLEASE GO VOTE- I YEAH I DID
THIS IS THIS IS THE MOST
UNLIKELY MEETING WE HAVE NOT
HAD THIS YET OCCUR THIS YEAR.
BUT IF I'VE LEARNED ANYTHING
FROM THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE TO
KNOW HOW TO PIVOT AND OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE BOTH- IT YOU WILL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY I'M SURE YOU ARE QUITE
FAMILIAR WITH THE ART OF
PIVOTING. SO I'M I'M GONNA
PIVOT TO OUR VICE CHAIR AND ASK
IF SHE WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS OR MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AND THEN- I'M SURE WE
WILL COME BACK TO SENATOR COM
LONGER AND YOU WILL GET A
CHANCE TO START OVER. MISTER
LIKE. WE NOTE BUT OKAY. PHOTO
MY THE GOOD SENATOR LA WITH
TALKING ABOUT THE
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS AND
IT'S PROBABLY ON ALL OF OUR
MINDS AND FOOD IS LIKE A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AS YOU WELL KNOW
GOING- GOING THROUGH OUR OUR
PROCESS HERE AT THE
LEGISLATURE- AS WE SPEAK SEVEN
FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY TO BOTH
OF YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE BOTH OF YOU HAVE
INCREDIBLE CAREERS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HAVE CERTAINLY-
DONE DONE THE JOB HI AT EVERY
LEVEL THAT SHE'D BEEN
PERFORMING OUT IN ITS GREAT
TALK. TO SEE I ASKED WE LIKE TO
SAY WOMEN WHO ARE IN THOSE VERY
VERY HIGH POSITIONS WITHIN THE
FIXED REALLY IMPORTANT
PROFESSION CAN TO SHARE OF
BRAWN I AM SURE THAT YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH BOB THE SHERIFF
OF ORANGE COUNTY OUR FOUNDER
HUTCHINSON WHO SERVED IN LOS
ANGELES AND SEEM TO HAVE A
SIMILAR CAREER TO YOUR STYLE
WITH RETIRING AND THEN COMING
BACK TO BE THE SHARE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND I WAS VERY
EXCITED TO. BE ONE OF THE BOTH
THAT PUT IN THE PLACE AND OF
COURSE SHE'S PASSED ON AND THAT
WAS A MOMENT OF GREAT SADNESS
BUT AGAIN ON ALL OF YOU WHO
HAVE SEEN FOR MANY DIFFERENT
LEVELS OUT THROUGH YOUR CAREER
I THINK ARE SO WELL PLACED THAT
AS WE ENTER THIS NEW- I GUESS
I'D SAY THAT THIS NEW- NOT A
RENO THAT CERTAINLY THE NEW WAY
THAT WE VIEW LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND. ITS RELATIONSHIP TO OUR
COMMUNITY. FORTUNE SO I LIKE TO
ASK AND A OF YOU. IN YOUR
INTERVIEW- PER ISSUE OVER. TO
QUESTIONS FROM OUR RULE STAFF.
THAT YOU WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DECERTIFICATION PROCESS IN
IT FROM. THE MANNER IN WHICH IS
GOING TO BE LOGGED. IN
IMPLEMENTED THAT THERE SHOULD
BE. CERTAINLY SOME STANDARDS.
THAT FOLLOW SO JUST SHARE WITH
ME SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS THAT
YOU ARE LOOKING AT AS WE GET
CLOSER TO THAT BECOMING PERHAPS
YOUR RESPONSIBILITY- ANDAL
STANDARDS AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND I THINK BOTH
OF YOU MENTIONED. ARE PROCESS
ITSELF BECAUSE PROCESS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF.
HAVING SOMETHING WORK CORRECTLY
FAIRLY AND CONSISTENTLY AS WE
INTERVIEW. THOSE WHO MAY BE
SUBJECT TO CERTIFICATION-
ENOUGH ANYWHERE AWFUL ON KIND
OF AN OPEN ENDED QUESTION THAT.
ARE YOU COULD START OFF FIRST
OF CHAIR DEADLY IF YOU WILL AND
THEN I'LL GO. TO OUR SHARE OF
PRIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
YOU FOR APPRECIATING OUR
SERVICE AND I ALSO APPRECIATE
YOUR- IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS
THAT'S YET TO BE DETERMINED AND
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE RATHER
SPECIFIC BECAUSE- SURE RON HAS
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR HER
DEPARTMENT IN HER JURISDICTION.
THE FORTY CERTIFICATION AS YOU
WALMART POST HAD NO
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
DECERTIFICATION BECAUSE THAT
WASN'T THE CERTIFICATION HOST
ROLES VERY SPECIFIC AND VERY
CLEAR TRAINING. FOLLOW UP
TRAINING INFORMATION IN TERMS
OF RECRUITMENT. AND THEN BEYOND
THAT IT'S UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL
SHARE THE INDIVIDUAL THINGS
CHEAP TO TURN AROUND A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. CONTACT
DURING THE DAY IF THEY GET
FIRED IF THEY IF WHAT HAPPENS
THE NEW DESTINATION. SO WE
SUDDENLY ASKING POSED TO DO
SOMETHING IT HASN'T DONE BEFORE
BUT I PERSONALLY FEEL IS WELL
EQUIPPED TO DO IT ALL WILL BE
WELL EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH ONCE
WE GET THE RESOURCE. WE'RE
ASKING POST YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
SOMEONE. AND THIS SOMEONE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE DETERMINED
BY HOW THE LAW ITSELF WOULD BE
GREAT. IS IT GOING TO BE
SOMEONE WHO IS AN INVESTIGATION
THAT WAS DONE BY THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY COULD IT BE
SOMETHING DONE BY SEVERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TOGETHER
IT'S GOING TO BE DONE BY POSTED
THE VERY FIRST QUESTION. WHO'S
GOING TO DO THAT INITIAL
INVESTIGATION I KNOW THE LAW
HAS GONE THROUGH SOME
TRANSITIONS I DON'T KNOW WHERE
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN BUT IT
SHOULD BE RATHER SPECIFIC AS TO
THAT. AND THEN WHAT DOES POST
DO WITH THAT INFORMATION
ASSUMING THEY DID NOT CONDUCT
IT. HOW MUCH OF THAT TO THE
BEGINNING YEAH HOW MANY REVIEWS
THEY DO WHAT'S OF TURNING
FACTOR WHAT'S THE STANDARD
GOING TO BE IT'S GOING TO BE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT IT'S
GOING TO BE PREPONDERANCE IS IT
GOING TO BE. THIS PERSON HE WAS
SUSTAINED THEREFORE THAT'S A
NOT SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HIT MANY MEETINGS OF
PROFESSIONALS THROUGHOUT OUR
CAREERS IN ORDER TO ADD OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER TO DISCUSS WHAT SYSTEM
LOOK LIKE. AND THEN ONCE WE
HAVE IT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR TO DETERMINE SPECIFICALLY
WHAT THE ROLE IS GOING TO BE
CLOSE. BUT I HAVE NO DOUBT THE
IMPORTANCE SINCE I STARTED TO
SAY I THINK THIS IS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ALL OF YOUR
BASIC- BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS
TO TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
DETERMINING WHAT IS A PROBLEM
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. WE'VE
BEEN GIVEN THIS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT. AND I
THINK FOR ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS- WHY NO WATCH CHAU
BEEN COMMITTED MURDER. IT WAS A
DEGRADATION THE OF THE UNITS.
AND IT'S HAD RIPPLE EFFECT IN
TERMS MORALE TRIPS EVERY
ENTRANCE OF RETAIL. ONE FOUR
SEVEN I'M CLOSE TO WOULD BE
POUD TO HAVE DE SER PROCESS-
MANY FEEL WEIRD DOWN TO THE BAD
APPLES CERTAINLY NEED SYSTEMIC
EDUCATION BUT THERE ARE SOME
BAD APPLES AND I VERY MUCH WANT
TO SEE THOSE BAD APPLES GET OUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND NOT BE ABLE
TO FIND A JOB IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ANYWHERE ELSE.
THANK YOU. ENTERPRISE THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU FOR NOT
LOOKING AT SURPRISED SHE AND I
ONLY OVERLAPPED- BECAUSE THE
NETWORK NEEDS SO CRYING AND IT
SETS A GREAT EXAMPLE I WOULD
LOVE TO LIVE ACTIVE YEAH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING FOR I
THINK IT'S A GREAT LOSS IT'S
NOT HALF. IN. THE MARKET FOR.
CHECK OUT ONTO A- THEY SAY AND
I AGREE ACCURATE THAT SHE SAID
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE PROCESS.
AND PART OF THAT PROCESS IS
DOES THE- SO WHEN I AM LOOKING
TO TERMINATE A DEPUTY. WE DO
THE INVESTIGATION OR ITS-
ACTUALLY THE TERMINATION I WILL
HIRE AN OUTSIDE FIRM BECAUSE
I'M VERY SMALL TO KEEP MILLION
PT WHICH IS TEN THOUSAND SPARK.
HERE JUST. IF I WERE FULLY
STAFFED TWENTY SETS ONE
INCLUDING SO WE ARE TOO SMALL
TO DO TO BE INVESTIGATIONS
OURSELVES BECAUSE WE'RE TOO
CLOSE TO IT. SO I'LL HIRE AN
OUTSIDE FIRM TO DO IT. SO DOES
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INVESTIGATION THE STATE AND I
DECIDE TO TERMINATE. SOMEONE
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE CERTIFIED THAT. IS
POSTER REINVESTIGATION THEIR
SECOND. LIKE AN ARBITRATION OF
A LOCAL EIGHT WE NEED
VERIFICATION THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE STANDARDS IS STILL. WHAT
NEED TO DECIDE. NOT SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT FIRED FOR MONEY YOU
MIGHT NOT GET YOU FIRED FROM
ANOTHER. WHAT QUESTIONS THAT
ARE UNANSWERED WILL BE CLEAR.
MAKE SURE THAT WORKS BUT I THIS
KNOW THAT STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION THAT BY CONCEPT IF
YOU START HOW IS ONE VERY STATE
DOESN'T HAVE SIR PROCESS AND WE
NEED WE NEED TO HAVE THAT IN A
COMMUNITY EIGHT. SEE THAT WE
ARE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE WE'RE
DOING SO AT THE BUZZWORD
WAITRESS. SO THAT THEY KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON YOU CAN GO
ONLINE AND SEE IF YOUR
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE IT'S BEEN
ABOUT YOU CAN GO ONLINE AND SEE
IF YOU'RE DOCTORS LAST AND THAT
AND THAT SEEMS. REALLY UNFAIR.
SO DO SUPPORT. DECERTIFICATION
I JUST S. TERRIBLY EXACTLY ONCE
WE GOT RIGHT WANT TO BE FOR.
SHE DOES ONE PERSON OFFICERS.
AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. QUESTION IS SOMETHING
IF DOING YOUR JOB. THIS IS NICK
FAIR. YOU CAN IT- GOING HEAD OF
YOU IT'S JUST THE NATURAL
PROGRESSION IF YOU'RE UNDER
DOING YOUR TO THE BEST OF YOUR
ABILITY THE BEST YOUR TAX THE
OFFICE TO YOU WERE ARE VERY
SLIM. IT'S A GOING TO BE OUT
AND MAKE. THOSE PEOPLE THAT
SHOULD BE A LONG. I THINK ONE
OF THE- CONCERNS CAME UP IN
DISCUSS NOW WINDED WAS BE
PRESENT ON THE FLOOR AND
PERHAPS IN THE FACE COMMITTEE
OF WHICH I'M NOT A MEMBER
WITHOUT WHATEVER BODY IS
CREATED ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
REVIEW THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION. THAT
THEY BELIEVE THE TELEPHONE YOU
KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ESPECIALLY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHETHER A RANK AND FILE OFFICER
WOULD ALSO BE A MEMBER OF THE
BODY AND FELT THAT THAT WAS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT
PERSPECTIVE OBVIOUSLY YOU
WOULDN'T WANT TO BE INVOLVED
WITH SOMEONE THAT WITHIN YOUR
OWN ORGANIZATION. THAT
SPECIFICALLY TO YOU SHARE BROAD
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT
AND SEE IF BOB THAT SEEM TO BE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ENOUGH MUCH
OF THOSE WHO. HAVE A GREAT TIME.
YOUR LACK OF CALM AND
CREDIBILITY. CREDIBILITY OF A
PARTICULAR AGENCY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND THAT
THAT MIGHT BE A BIASED VIEW
THAT IT SEEMS WE'RE SEEKING
BALAFON EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
IMPORTANT TO HAVE. I DON'T FIND
APPEARING HERE ASPECT TO BE
OBJECTIONABLE I. OUR PEERS ARE
ACTUALLY PRETTY HARD ON EACH
OTHER. IN CASES WHERE I NEEDED
OUT DISCIPLINE AND THE STAFF
HAS COME BACK IT SHOULD BE
MORE- YEAH AND THEY DON'T KNOW
ALL THE FACTS THE CASES AND
SHOOT WHY NOT DECISIONS THAT I
MAKE- BUT- HERE YOU ASPECT I
KNOW TAT THE UP WALKING. THEY
HAVE VERY GRAPHIC AT LEAST
RESOURCE REPORTS WE HAVE. LINE
LEVEL OFFICERS ON THE POST YOU
SHOULD BETTER RECENT BECAUSE
EVERYONE'S OUT THERE IF YOU
NEED A JOB. NO I DON'T WELL
ACTUALLY DEAL BECAUSE I WERE
INFORMED MAKE TRAFFIC STOPS IN
THE SMALL COUNTY BUT I DON'T
ACTUALLY GO OUT AND ANSWER
CALLS AND DO THE JOB RIGHT
ANSWER YOU. KNOW THE MAKE
DECISIONS. SO IT SHOULD BE SOME
WHO HAS IT. A WORKING LEVEL
CURRENT UNDERSTAND OF WHAT THE
I DON'T FIND THAT IT'S- WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOU RESPONSE FROM
I INTEND TO SPUR BOTH OF YOU
ARE STRONG. I THINK YOU READ
FONG QUALIFY SIGNIFICAN FOR ALL
OF THIS YEAR AND GOING TO BE A
WANTED TWO WE GET THROUGH I
THINK OF THE CURRENT TRAVEL
LACK OF TRUST OF WHAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS SO FAR I HAVE A
NUMBER OF FAMILY MEMBERS OVER
THE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN A LOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO I KNOW- THE
STRESSES THAT PUTS ON THE
FAMILY I KNOW HOW FOR A MOMENT-
OF EACH OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
DATE WEEKS AND THEN FIGHT IT
TENDS TO CHANGE- THE WAY THEY
LOOK AT THINGS AND THEY HAVE TO
THEY NEED THOSE SOBRE EITHER
SIDE TO GET BACK. WITH A BETTER
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE WHEN YOU
WALK OUT THE DOOR YOU DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'RE COMING BACK TO
YOUR FAMILY SO YOU'RE ALWAYS IN
THE SIEGE MENTALITY I THINK IS
WHAT. WOULD HAPPEN SINCE SO-
PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES TO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SOLVE
VERY IMPORTANT DENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SHOULD ALWAYS BE
AVAILABLE AND I KNOW ALL OF
THIS SHOULD BE DISCUSSED AS
YOU'RE LOOKING OUT. CREATING
THE PROCESS AND- IMPACTING
SOMEBODY'S LIFETIME CAREER
WHERE THEY MAKE SOME SERIOUS
HORRIBLE MISTAKES IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME WHO KNOWS WHY
AND I THINK THE WHY OF THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT YEAH AS WE GO
FORWARD TO DETERMINING WHO'S
FAT- TO CONTINUE TO SERVE. ARE
NOT BE TO CERTAIN THE CERTIFIED
BUT BUT MAYBE GIVEN THAT SECOND
CHANCE IF THAT'S POSSIBLE WITH
BEHAVIOR MODIFICATION THAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED THE WITHOUT- I
WILL- AGAIN GIVE YOU HIGH FIVES
BOTH OF YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU ARE TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR YOUR APPOINTMENT-
YOU SEEM SO VERY WELL QUALIFIED
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOU AT THE. APPROPRIATE MOMENT
THANK YOU. HE SAID. THANK YOU
ARE MAN OF HERE- I WILL JUST
SAY. THEY GAVE. PRETTY GREAT
ANSWERS ON THE- THESE. HOWEVER
IT WAS- MINIMIZED TEARS. MAJOR
QUESTION. SO I THEY MAY HAVE TO
REPEAT SOME OF THAT- BUT I WANT
TO GIVE YOU THAT HEADS UP. AND
AGAIN WITH MY APOLOGIES TO THE
COMMISSIONERS BUT- MY GO TO-
SENATOR GROW FIRST AND WE'LL
SEE WHAT SHE HAS TO ADD AND- GO
FROM THERE. THANKS THANK YOU
I'M M. MATTER PRO TEMP. THANK
YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
APPOINTMENT APPOINTMENT OF
THEM. TO VERY QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS. I HAVE TO SAY THAT-
SHERIFF BRIAN- MY SHIRTS ARE
DONNY YOUNGBLOOD IN MIKE
BOUDREAU. AT AND MEET MY
DISTRICT AND- I SENT THEM A
TEXT AND SAID WHAT DO YOU
THINK. AND THEY SAID YOU WERE
ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL AND DAT-
YOU ARE VERY FAIR AND BALANCED
AND YOU WERE VERY GOOD AT WHAT
YOU DO AND THEY SUPPORT YOU.
AND. AND ONE EVEN SAID SHE
LOVES ME. AT YOU CAN GUESS
WHICH ONE THAT IS AT. I'M
PRETTY SURE I'M- OKAY GREAT ARE
THERE AND THAT'S THAT'S HIGH
PRAISE FROM BOTH OF THEM IT'S
POLITICALLY WE DON'T ALWAYS
AGREE SO THAT'S THAT. YOU KNOW
THEY MADE THAT COMMENT AS WELL
POLITICALLY I DON'T ALWAYS
AGREE BUT AT YOU ARE AN
OUTSTANDING INDIVIDUAL SO- THAT
SPOKE VOLUMES- FROM BOTH OF THE
GENTLEMEN THAT BENNETT THAT
REPRESENT- MY COMMUNITIES. SO
BOTH OF YOU I MEAN BEING
ASSIGNED TO THE POST AT. I
GUESS A POST THE TRAINING
PROGRAM- SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I HAVE QUESTIONS ON- AND I
HOPE I DON'T DUPLICATE ANY
QUESTIONS I APOLOGIZE I'VE
WE'VE BEEN BOUNCING BACK AND
FORTH AND I KNOW THE SENATE PRO
TEM GABY THE REASON WE RAN OUT
OF THAT THE COMMITTEE HEARING.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS AT
ABOUT- SHOULD PEACE OFFICERS BE
LICENSED BY THE STATE IN A T.
AND IF SO DO YOU THINK THAT-
POST IS THE RIGHT ENTITY TO
PROVIDE THAT LICENSE. AND I CAN
DIRECT THAT TO ON A GERMAN
DEADLY FIRST- TREMENDOUSLY AND
THEN AM SURE PRIME. I THINK
YOU'RE A NEAT MA'AM. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND I'D LIKE TO ADD MY
POSSUM OR SPEED SHARE BROWN AS
WELL. RIGHT I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE WHAT YOU MEAN BY LICENSED
BY THE STATE COULD YOU TELL ME
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT
YOU HAD IN MIND. SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE A DECERTIFICATION
PROCESS OR A LICENSING PROCESS
THAT COULD. GO THROUGH THE
SYSTEM. AND IF SO I GUESS MY
KEEP MY CURIOUS QUESTION IS
THAT. I KNOW YOU'D BE BOUND BY
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BUT
WITH BOTH OF YOUR EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU BOTH HAVE.
DO YOU THINK THAT. THE POST
ORGANISER THE POST FACILITY OR
ORGANIZATION SHOULD BE THE
LICENSING. AGENCY AND THE
DECERTIFICATION AGENCY. OR
SHOULD IT RESIDE IN A-
DIFFERENT AGENCY I GUESS. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU CHIP- POST
COULD HANDLE THIS SHOULD
HAMPERS OR AGENCY. I THINK IT
SHOULD NOT BE A LOCAL ISSUE I
THINK IT NEEDS TO BE A
STATEWIDE ISSUE I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE CONSISTENT I
BELIEVE IT HOST THEIR VERY HIGH
LEVELS OF EXPECTATION FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ON. AND I
THINK THAT SERVING AS A
COMMISSIONER I HOPE TO BE
REINSTATED THAT IT WOULD BE THE
THING I'M MST PASSIONATE ABOUT
AND THAT'S MAKING SURE THAT THE
PROCESS THERE IS DUE PROCESS
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. I CAN'T
IMAGINE ANOTHER AGENCY IN THE
STATE THAT WOULD BE BETTER
EQUIPPED. THANK YOU MA'AM
SHERIFF. I COMPLETELY AGREE
THAT- SHOULD BE BECAUSE POSTED
THE CERTIFYING AGENCY THEY
ISSUE THE BASIC AND ALL THE
OTHER CERTIFICATE INTERMEDIATE
ADVANCED AND THEY TRACK LL OF
THAT INFORMATION IS THAT RIGHT
IS THAT WHERE THAT KNOWLEDGE
SLICE THOSE STOPS BE AGENCIES
TO HANDLE DECERTIFICATION AND
IT IT DOES NEED TO BE A STATE
AGENCY. AT ONE LOCATION AT THAT
LEVEL IT SHOULD NOT BE A LOCAL
AGENCY DECERTIFY. THINK YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE LOCAL LEVEL TO
TERMINATE RECOMMEND FOR
DECERTIFICATION BUT IT NEEDS TO
REST WITH THAT WOULD POST A
POST I BELIEVE WILDLIFE FIVE
ANNIE ALVAREZ YOU CAN BE EASY
MARKETS GREAT STAFF IT WILL
CREATE AN EXTRA LAYER OF
WORKLOAD FOR SURE ESPECIALLY.
AT. THE BEGINNING THIS IS
SORTED OUT. DETERMINED WHAT ALL
THE TO HAPPEN THERE ARE A LOT
OF MANY. BURKE SET BACK POST
ITS BEST BUT YOU CAN JUST.
THERE'S NO OTHER THAT REALLY
USE RIGHT NOW MAYBE ENTRAINED
GENERAL BUT THAT WOULDN'T
REALLY BE EITHER. YEAH CURFEW.
IT SEEING IF THEY HAVE ONE
COURSE NOT WHO WERE AND I'M
THAT WE BE AN AWKWARD POSITION
THEM TO BE IN THAT THAT CHARTER
CREATING A NEW STATE. HE WAS A
LOT YOUR- IT'S PAST EQUIPPED
FOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH
FOR THAT I DO AN AND EXCUSE ME
INNER ON THIS A IT DOES PAY
HAVE- RIGHT AND FILE AN OFFICER
ASSIST WITH. SO NO POST THAT
OVERSIGHT- EIGHT IN FOUR
STANDARD IN TRAINING THEY HAVE
TO RETIRE. FORCE BEFORE FOR
THEM BURKE THANK YOU THEY
REALLY ARE IT YOU CANNOT DO
OUTDONE ASK IT'S- BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE IS. SWORN NEVER
AT FORCE NETWORK. THANK YOU
RIGHT WE THINK YOU SHERIFF AT
AGE DRUG DEADLY D. YOU HAVE YOU
HAVE A CAR ONE DAY. YOU'RE A
MUTE MAN. WE HAVE A SO IS MADE
UP OF THE COMMITTEE BUT WE ARE
HAVE A THAT GIVES THAT WORKS IN
THE FIELD THAT GIVES US
FEEDBACK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE FIELD SO THEY REPORT TO
THE COMMISSION AND THAT'S JUST
A SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
COMMISSION- IN TERMS OF WHETHER
ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
SWARMED GUNS BADGES ALSO WORK
AT PROS IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT SOMEBODY CAN TAKE A LEAVE
OF ABSENCE THEIR JOBS AND COME
TO PROTEST DURING THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE CLOSED I DON'T NEED A
WHOLE POST POSITIONS. ARE AT
LEAST I HAVEN'T HEARD OF IT I
HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE THINGS I
SUSPECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE IF EITHER
DUPLICATE QUESTIONS BUT THEY
ARE A HOT SUBJECT MATTERS. AT
YOU KNOW WE'RE LIKE DEALING
WITH THE STANDARD OF USE OF
FORCE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S GUIDELINES WERE ADOPTED
EARLIER THIS YEAR AT CAN YOU
EITHER ONE TELL ME WHAT- IF
BRUCE IS DOING WHAT KIND OUT
REACH OR IF THEY ARE DOING
OUTREACH TO LOCAL AGENCIES- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE GUIDELINES
ARE ENCOURAGED OR IS THERE A
PROCESS. IN PLACE I'LL START
THE DIRECTOR. THANK YOU-
CERTAINLY POSES DOING OUTREACH
THEY'RE VERY LOTS OF ATHLETES-
THEY DID SOMETHING QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY EARLY ON. WHEN
THE BILL HAD NOT YET PASSED-
THEY ASKED ME AND I ASKED TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S LETTER
PARKS THE STATE. TO JOIN ME IN
DISCUSSING IF THE LEGISLATION
PASSED WHAT WOULD IT BE. SO WE
GOT TOGETHER VERY EARLY WE MADE
A VIDEO THE VIDEO IS STILL
AVAILABLE SO THAT WE WOULD HAVE
READY TO GO. YOU BEGIN TO TELL
PEOPLE THIS IS AREN'T CRASHING
ABOUT WHAT THE CHANGE IN THE
LAW WOULD BE TWO YEARS. SINCE
THEN THEY'VE CREATED CLASSES.
PROPERTIES VIDEOS OUT. AND
THERE'S BEEN- TREMENDOUS AND ON
THIS BECAUSE YOU CAN WELL. AND
I THINK THE SHURIKEN SPEAK TO
THIS BETTER THERE WAS LOTS OF
ANXIETY AROUND THE PASSING THIS
LAW AND HOW WOULD THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ABILITY.
TO DO THEIR JOB- SO THEREFORE
THE INTEREST IS THERE I KNOW
LONG BEFORE GOES WAS INVOLVED
THIS DISTRICT ATTORNEY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES LOOK WITH
RESPECT IF THIS PASSES ARE YOU
GOING TO CHANGE. THE WAY YOU
EXAMINE OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS USE OF FORCE. AND SO
EARLY ON WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING
TO BE A TOPIC THAT REQUIRED A
LOT OF OUTREACH AND I THINK
BECAUSE IT'S- BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN DOING THAT. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE THAT EFFORT.
BUT IT. THAT YES CLOSE THE-
EVERY THAT THEIR SCHOOL TO DO
HIM MORE. IT IS THIS AGREEMENT
THEY OUT TRAINING WILL LEAD
STATE THAT THE TRAINING VIDEO
THEY'VE INSURED THE BASIC
ECONOMY CORPORATION IT CHANGES.
I KNOW BECAUSE I. AN
ADMINISTRATOR THAT ONE FIRST
MADE IT SEEM WE GET FOLKS BOOK
AND THEY SET LAST WEEK IS GET
THEM TO OUR STAFF. THEY HAVE A
MAKE SURE THAT THAT EVERY IS
EVERY COURSE NATION BUSCA. AND
THAT. THAT WE ARE WELL AWARE
BECAUSE HE AND YEAH. IMPACT OF
THE CHANGE ONLINE HOW TO APPLY
FOR EACH AGENCY SAID THAT
INFORMATION IS WIDELY.
DISTRIBUTED BY. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH THREE
QUESTION AND THEM. SURE FRIDAY
STEM. I KNOW THAT I BELIEVE
THAT YOU ENSURE OF MAN'S ARE AT
ARE THERE ANY OTHER. WOMEN
SHERIFFS AND OUR STATE. THERE
ARE. NONE SURE SHANNON MOON
OKAY. NEVADA COUNTY AND- ONE
MORE AND IT'S A SKILL START OF
COURSE LAURIE SMITH- WOOD
COUNTY- THAT'S OKAY AM I JUST
THINKING AT LEAST WE'RE GETTING
THAT THERE RIGHT FOR AT IF AT
FIFTY EIGHT WE HAVE WE HAVE
FIVE- SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY.
OKAY YOU KNOW SHERIFF VICKI
HENNESSY THIS YEAR TAX OUT
EVERY ELECTION NEXT YEAR SO
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE SOME ONLINE
WOMEN CANDICE'S UP YES THEY
ARE. WERE 50% OF THE POPULATION
ALTHOUGH I THINK YOU'RE. A 100%
OF THIS COMMITTEE. WILL YOU GO
GIRLS. YEAH GRADUATIONS VERY
MUCH I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING BOTH OF YOU CENTER
I'D LIKE TO SHARE IT U WITH
BIG PROPERTY WHEN I WAS FIRST
ELECTED DISTRICT ATTORNEY
COMELEC HARRIS MYSELF NANCY
O'MALLEY THERE WERE EIGHT OF US
I BELIEVE AND THERE ARE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES AS WE ARE WILL
NOW. TWO YEARS AGO. THREE YEARS
AGO- WE PASSED THE NUMBER. SO
NOW WE'VE GOT EIGHT TO WONDER
WHAT THE MAJORITY. SO NEAR DOWN
THERE ARE DOUBTS. SO TWENTY SIX
FEMALE LIKE DID DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS FROM EIGHT I STARTED
WHICH WAS TWENTY. YES SO AT.
FIVE THE GROWTH YES AND I HAVE
ONE OF THOSE IN KERN COUNTY AND
SHE'S A ROCK STAR SO. AND THANK
YOU MA'AM FOR THAT INFORMATION
YOU GUYS HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING BOTH OF YOU. THANK
YOU. YEAH THANK YOU CENTER.
CALM WATER BACK TO YOU. THANK
YOU AND I APOLOGIZE TO BOTH OF
YOU ALL FOR. ASKING SUCH A LONG
WINDED QUESTION AND THEN-
HAVING TO LEAVE- SO- APOLOGIES
AGAIN. SO I WON'T START THEIR-
I'LL OUT- IN SOME OF YOUR
RESPONSES TO DO CERTAIN MAY
CAME UP COME UP IN SOME OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS- BUT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT- USE OF FORCE.
AND- CHAIRWOMAN DEADLY I GUESS
I'LL ASK YOU MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT- THERE ISN'T ANY
PROSECUTORIAL TEETH ASSOCIATED
WITH- THREE NINE TWO- ALTHOUGH
IT DOES CREATE A DIFFERENT
STANDARD- SO. AND THEN I KNOW
THAT AND YOU ALSO MENTION THIS
THAT THERE ARE- THE VOLUNTARY-
VIDEOS THAT WERE MADE AFTER
THAT- TO OUR TRAININGS ON THE
NEW STANDARDS- WHICH A NUMBER
OF- OFFICERS AND AGENCIES-
COMPLETED SO. GENERALLY
SPEAKING GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THERE THERE THERE THERE WASN'T
THAT TEETH AND I KNOW THAT WAS
A BONE OF CONTENTION FOR A
NUMBER OF FOLKS DURING THE TIME
THAT THE LEGISLATION WAS BEING
DISCUSSED- WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS GENERALLY ON THE
CHANGE. I KNOW YOU'RE ALSO A
PROSECUTOR SO YEAH. THANK YOU
SENATOR I HAVE TO MAKE THE
TOUGH DECISION ABOUT WHETHER TO
FILE HOMICIDE CASES AT ALL OUR
WEATHER TEAM SPORTS YEAH HEY
HOW WAS THAT CASE WOULDN'T
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE CASE SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
DURING RIGHT NOW GETTING TO
THIRTY TWO YEARS IS EVALUATING
CASE. SO WHEN I LOOK AT AN
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING CASE.
NINE WOULD BE USED WORST CASE.
WHAT I HAVE TO LOOK AT IS THE
WALK IN THE STANDS THE
STANDARDS CHANGED WITH THE NEW-
USE OF FORCE LOCK AND IS
ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING I WOULD
CONSIDER WHEN CONSIDERING
WHETHER TO FILE ON THE SITE
CHARGES AGAINST. WHICH POPS.
OKAY WANT TO GIVE ME HOPE- I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DISCUSSED OUR IN OUR-
CONVERSATION WITH ONE ANOTHER
IS TRAINING AND IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY YEAR THE LEGISLATURE IS
ASKING FOR OPPOSED TO DO MORE
TRAINING- AND THIS IS ACTUALLY
FOR BOTH OF YOU AND I GUESS
I'LL LET- SHERROD BROWN GO
FIRST. I THINK SOMETIMES IN
THIS IS MY PERSONAL BELIEF THAT
TRAINING CAN BECOME UBIQUITOUS
WITH KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD. AND YOU KNOW WHEN IT IS
TRAINING TOO MUCH AND NOT
GETTING TO THE ROOT OF THE
ISSUE- AND ARE THERE OTHER WAYS
THAT WE CAN BE ENGAGING POST.
AND HELPING TO MAKE SURE THAT
OFFICERS GET. THE GUIDELINES
AND THE SUPPORT- AND GUIDANCE
THAT THEY NEED- TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS KIND OF WORK IN A WAY
THAT KEEPS THEM AND THOSE THAT
THEY ARE PROTECTING SAFE.
SHERIFF. I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
YOU THERE IS A LOT OF MANDATED
TRAINING THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
FIX IF SOMETHING GOES WRONG
WELL THEY WERE TREATED FOR LESS
RESPECT WHAT STRAIGHT MAKE SURE
THEY MAKE SURE THEY KNOW AND
IT'S TRUE THEY SHOULD KNOW ALL
THE THINGS THAT THERE'S A
SATURATION POINT WHERE YOU
DON'T KNOW SIR I'M. YEAH AT. I
WAS SPEAKING WITH A LITTLE
DEEPER YESTERDAY. RESEARCHING
AND SORT OF BRAINSTORMING GET
OUT OF THE TRAINING MORE EFFECT
AND HOW DO YOU. AT WHETHER
TRADING IN WORKING HOW DO WE
KNOW WORKING AT THERE YEAH IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE AT. ONE OF THE
CONCEPTS EACH JUST THAT BASIC
BASIC POST AND THAT IT IS ADDED
AND MAYBE TWO. OF FOLLOW. UP
WORKS FOR ALL THE LOS. AFTER
YOU HAD BASIC YOU HAVE A YEAR
TO WORK THE FIELDS GO BACK IT
YOU OR LONG. SHE TRAINING IT
HOW HOW. WHAT TO WHAT YOU DO.
HOW MUCH DID YOU FROM WHAT WHAT
WAS THE FEEL DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THEY FEEL. AND WHAT YOU IN
THE ACADEMY. SO I. THOUGHT THAT
WAS A REALLY IDEA TO HAVE
SOMEBODY TO GO BACK THROUGH.
AND SEE CONTRASTING COMPARED TO
WHAT YOU WERE TAUGHT TO WHAT
YOU ACTUALLY GET. AND HOW MUCH
DID IT HOW. MUCH OF IT TOOK AND
HOW MUCH OF IT. SENIOR OUT.
YEAH IT. THE TRAINING AND I
THINK A LOT AT IT NOW THAT WE
ALL BODY WORKING IN MIND IF I
WEREN'T HERE THE AT MAYBE TO
GIVE I DISAGGREGATED STUDY A
VIDEO THIS HE MUCH. YOUR
TRAINING IS THAT USED TO FEEL
YOU KNOW HOW WELL HOW THE
TACTICS YOU SEE INCIDENTS OF
RAPES BIAS TO SEE IF THERE
WHERE. I THINK HER YEAH FOR IT
LATER IN THE SEASON WHERE
THINGS ARE BEING HANDLED WELL.
WE HEAR ABOUT THE THAT GO
BECAUSE THEY WERE. BUT ALSO
EVERY. ONE PERSON OFFICERS ARE
DOING THEIR AND THEY'RE DOING
THE RIGHT HERE ABOUT IT BECAUSE
DOING THEIR JOB. RIGHT BUT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED BE. THAT WOULD
BE ALSO SOMETHING THAT TRICK
THAT. WE CAN LOOK AT AND SAY
WHAT EVERY DAY. THEY'RE DOING
GOOD THANKS. SO IT. IT WOULD BE
A GOOD. TO GO AND LOOK. WHAT
WE'RE EVERY DAY IN OUR MAKE IT
RIGHT. AND FINALLY TO. AT THAT.
THANK YOU. COMMISSIONER DEADLY
CHAIR. UP IT'S A GREAT IDEA
SHARE I AM I TOOK ON I THINK
ADULT VIDEOS FANTASTIC. I'M NOT
INTERESTED IN WHETHER AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER CAN SPIT
BACK THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
WERE GIVEN IN THE CLASS I'M
INTERESTED DO THEY ACTUALLY
LIVE WHEN THEIR APPS FIELD
THAT'S WE KNOW THE TRAINING WAS
SUCCESSFUL AND I LOVE THE IDEA
OF LOOKING AT THOSE VIDEOS THE
SAME WHEN IT DIDN'T WORK AND
WHEN IT DID WORK AND FOCUSING
ON G. LET'S LOOK AT THE NOW
LET'S DO A DEEPER DIVE AND SEE
WE'RE TRAINING THE CURRENT IN
THE AREA WHERE THEY WORK WELL
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
IN ONE JURISDICTION. IT DIDN'T
WORK FOR ANOTHER. WE ALL OF US
WHETHER WE'RE TRAVEL LAYERS OR
LEGISLATORS I ASSUME. SOMETHING
BECOMES RELEVANT WHEN WE HAVE
TO BEFORE. YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S DISCUSSING YOUR BILL OR IF
YOU NEED WHEN I USED TO BE A
TRY WE'RE GOING TO TRIAL. I HAD
NO INTEREST IN ARTS AND UNTIL I
HAVE PROSECUTED ARSON MURDER
CRIME AND THEN I WANT TO BE AN
ARSON EXPERTS BECAUSE I DIDN'T
WANT TO LOOK LIKE. WHO DID NOT
STAND ARE SET. SO MANY THINGS
WE TEACH IN THE ACADEMY AREN'T
RELEVANT UNTIL THEY'RE
RELEVANT. SO ANOTHER PART TO
THIS IS I WOULD NOT ONLY ONE TO
TWO YEAR FOLLOW UP. TO YOUR
QUESTION. THAT TALKED ABOUT
THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES AND
SPECIFICALLY SAY. TELL US YOU
TOOK A CLASS IN THE US. TELL US
WHEN YOU APPLY THIS IN THIS
SITUATION AND WHAT HAPPENED. I
LOVE ALL THAT MUCH BECAUSE HAS
THE ABILITY TO TAKE ON ALL
THAT. I'M TAKING NOTES NOW BE
TALKING TO DIRECTOR OPERATES. I
LOVE WITH FOLKS GET HOMEWORK. I
AM. DO YOU THINK THAT YOU ARE
ABLE TO- GATHER HONEST FEEDBACK
ON THE IMPACT THAT THE
TRAININGS HAVE ON THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE OF A
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT. YOU KNOW
DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT YOU
PROBABLY HAVE TO ESTABLISH A
BASELINE. YOU KNOW ON THE
CULTURE WITHIN THAT DEPARTMENT
RIGHT THE CHALLENGES WITH
RECRUITMENT WITH RETENTION. YOU
KNOW HAVING SOME SORT OF HONEST
ASSESSMENT OF THE DEFICIENCIES
WHICH SHOULDN'T NECESSARILY
COME FROM LEGISLATURE LET'S
JUST SAY THE LEGISLATURE- ARE
YOU GUYS ABLE TO. GET THAT
INFORMATION WOULD THAT ALSO BE
SOMETHING HELPFUL TO YOU TO
HAVE. YEAH IT'S A FUN FOR YOUR
TWO YEAR POLICE OFFICER YOU'RE
PROBABLY GONNA GET A MORE
HONEST ANSWER THING YOU'RE-
CRANKY TWENTY FIVE YEAR-
CRESSKILL COP DOESN'T. YEAH
I'VE BEEN THERE DONE THAT KIND
OF THING BUT FROM YOUR YOUNGER
OFFICERS- THEY CERTAINLY
INVOLVED FROM WHEN I FIRST CAME
OUT THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND IF
YOU ESTABLISHED THAT DIALOGUE
IS. THE ABILITY TO GO BACK AND
FORTH. I THINK YOU CAN GET I
THINK I COULD WALK TO BE MY DAD
RIGHT NOW THEY'LL GIVE YOU AN
HONEST ANSWER TO ANYTHING.
WE'RE A SMALL AGENCY AND WORK
FIRST NAME BASIS. I LOST MY
FIRST NAME WHEN I GOT LUCKY
SURE BUT- WE DO HAVE THAT KIND
OF CONVERSATION. AB YEAH. I
DON'T KNOW THEY WOULD NEED TO
HAVE SOME SORT OF. ASSURING
THAT THEY CAN SPEAK OPENLY.
THAT'S ALWAYS A CONCERN HOW
MUCH AM I GOING TO GET PUNISHED
IF I SAY SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
MY BOSS BOB I'M NOT GONNA SAY
IT LAST NIGHT I'M CERTAIN THAT
THERE'S NO REPERCUSSIONS OR
SAYING. YEAH IT WOULD NEED TO
BE SOME SORT OF ASSURANCE. THAT
THEY CAN'T SPEAK LIKE AND OTHER.
YOU'RE I'M I GUESS ASK THIS OF-
CHAIR DOUBLE. HOW YOU AND WE TO
A BIT ABOUT THIS EARLIER TODAY
HOW HOW DO YOU DETERMINE WHEN
THE TRAINING ISN'T WORKING- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT. DOES THAT
CRITERIA LOOK LIKE OR WHAT ARE
THE DETERMINANTS. WHAT WHAT
WOULD BE WHAT AGAIN GOING BACK
TO THEIR ACTIONS IF WE ANALYZE
AN OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING
AND WE SEE HERE READING ABOUT
SOME VERY BAD DECISIONS BEING
MADE WE GO BACK TO THE TRAINING
AND STATE WHAT LET'S TAKE A
VERY CLOSE LOOK AT THIS
PARTICULAR OFFICER WHAT
TRAINING TO BE HAPPY AND THEN
WE HAVE TO TAKE A SERIOUS LOOK
AT THE TRAINING WASN'T THIS
PARTICULAR OFFICER. WHO DIDN'T
GET IT WHAT WAS THAT THE
QUALITY OF THE TRAINING I LOVE
THE IDEA OF LOOKING VIDEOS
BECAUSE THEN YOU COULD LOOK AT
A LOT OF DIFFERENT VIDEO SO WE
COULD GATHER TWENTY BIT MANY OF
THE STOCKS ARE ABOUT SHRINK.
SHOOTINGS ARE NOW ON VIDEO WE
CAN GATHER THAT STATE WHERE THE
OUTLINES YEAR WITH THE PROBLEMS
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE IS THAT
WHEN SOMEONE COMES TOWARD YOU
WITH A KNIFE SO WHEN THEY COME
TOWARD YOU WITH THE CAR- WHAT'S
THE DISTANCE AND ALL OF THAT IS
OCCURRING. AND THROUGH LOOKING
AT VIDEOS AND THROUGH ANALYZING
SITUATIONS AND IN TERMS OF THE
QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED TO
SHARE WELL I THINK THE IDEA OF
HOW YOU GET ON THE STREET THAT.
AND I THINK YOU CAN DO THAT TO
SOME EXTENT WITH THE-
QUESTIONNAIRES IS ALSO
QUESTIONS WELL WRITTEN AND I
THINK THEY CAN BE WELL WRITTEN
BY PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SO I CAN
OFTEN READ ONE OF THESE CAPS IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW DEFENDANTS IN
TERMS BINOCULARS VERY USED IN
SATURDAY AND THEY TALK ABOUT
HOW THEY WERE ABLE TO CHANGE.
THEIR BELIEFS IN THAT PERSON'S
ANSWER SO LET'S USE OUR
SCIENTISTS. NOT PSYCHOLOGISTS
TO GET THAT TO. YEAH I AND I
WAS JUST SPEAKING. TO USER FOR.
I THINKING ABOUT- ALL OF THE-
RIGHT THAT YOU ARE ARE IN-
REQUIRED TO DO ARE ENCOURAGED
TO DO. I DON'T KNOW SURE FRONT
IF YOU WANTED TO ADD. THE CARD-
DO EITHER OF YOU THINK AND I'LL
LET YOU SURE FRONT GO FIRST
THAT WE'RE DOING ENOUGH AS IT
RELATES TO- THE MENTAL HEALTH.
OF OFFICERS- THAT WE- HIRE AND
HAVE THAT IS BECOMING A BIGGER
AND BIGGER ISSUE- FOR GENERAL
DISCUSSION BUT ALSO AS IT
RELATES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT- I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL HAVE TO
REVEAL ITSELF AND- TRAININGS
WHICH OF COURSE I JUST TOLD YOU
I'M LEERY OF- TO SOME EXTENT
BUT- ARE. ARE YOU SEEING THAT
IS SORT OF THE NEXT. HURDLE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
OVERCOME. I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR OFFICE
DIRECT. RIGHT SO THAT IS A BIG
CONCERN BECAUSE- SUICIDE IS.
MUCH HIGHER MOST LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THAN ANY
OTHER FASHION AND OF COURSE WE
HAVE ACCESS THAT MEANS A LOT
MORE THAN OTHERS DO SO IT IS A
STRESSFUL JOB AND IT IS ALSO. A
MACHO JOB WE DON'T WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. ANY SORT OF THIS
SEVEN TO SAY THAT YOU NEED HELP
IS THERE A SIGN OF WEAKNESS. SO
IT'S HARD TO ASK FOR HELP WITH
YOUR- SO HOW DO YOU SEE ALL-
AND OVER IN THE SURE THAT.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND. YOU JUST
HAVE TO SEND THEM. TO HELP EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVEN'T ASKED FOR
IT SO WE NOT MUCH HAPPENS
YOU'RE GONNA COUNTY IT'S VERY
SMALL. YOU DON'T GET A LOT OF
CRIMES BUT WHEN SOMETHING DOES
HAPPEN IT'S SUPER TRAUMATIC IT
MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT I
THOUGHT HUNDRED FACSIMILE HE
INDICATED IT DOESN'T BOTHER
LEVINE I DON'T THINK HE'S
MAKING OR SEEN THAT OR- NOT.
THAT MEANT EVERYTHING THAT'S
RIGHT SOMEONE. TO COUNSELING-
AND WE USE OUR PURPOSE AND
CAN'T BREAKING UP BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT RESOURCE HERE
AND SAID GO. TALK DON'T TALK.
ABOUT IT YOU NEED TO GO AND
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY. TO TALK
WITH SOMEBODY AND SEE IF IT'S
REALLY BOTHERING YOU OR IF
YOU'RE OKAY WITH IT. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE OKAY. SO
MENTAL HEALTH IS SUPER
IMPORTANT FOR LONG PART BEFORE
STANDING AND- TIED INTO THAT IS
PHYSICAL HEALTH PHYSICAL
FITNESS. YOUR MARKET YOU ARE
PHYSICALLY THE MARKET YOU'RE
GOING TO BE EXACTLY- INTO ALLOW
TIME FOR PEOPLE SHE- AS SHE
DOES. IT'S A SUPER. STRESSFUL
PHYSICAL SOMETIMES WE NEED TO
SURE THAT WE AT BASICALLY IN
THE MOST. FOR IT TO FIRST.
AMONG OUR PEERS. IS FALLING ON.
EMOTIONALLY IF THERE'S- TO GET
AID. HI INCIDENT THEY WITNESS
YEAH AREN'T WITH THE WELL. YEAH
THE RESOURCES. IN WE HAVE.
COUNSELORS HE'S JUST HANK OR OF
SIGN UP ALL. WORST CASE
SCENARIO YOU REALLY THINK
SUMMER THE HARD STUFF TO TAKE
THEIR WEAPONS AWAY THEM UNTIL
THEY HAVE SEEN AND- IT'S THAT
THERE GOT YOUR- WE NEED TO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PRESERVE
THEIR MENTAL. BECAUSE IF
THEY'RE NOT MEANT FIT AND THERE
ARE STREET. THEY'RE DOING
THEY'RE NOT DOING THEIR JOB
THEY'RE GOING TO SERVICE THE
COMMUNITY AND THAT COULD CAUSE
FURTHER CLARK. AND I DON'T WANT
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR PUTTING
SOMEBODY OUT OF STATE BUT
THEY'RE NOT EMOTIONALLY OR
ACTUALLY. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
MADAM CHAIR I JUST HAVE TWO
MORE QUESTIONS I'LL ASK THIS
ONE OF- COMMISSIONER DEADLY.
AND YOU AS YOU KNOW I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES AND WE HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES AND IN OUR DISTRICT-
SO GIVEN THE PROLIFERATION OVER
THE DECADE OF CRIMINAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GANGS- AND I'M
THINKING ABOUT SPECIFICALLY OUT
THE LA SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT-
WE'RE WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF
INFORMATION- WHAT. IN POSTS
SELECTION CRITERIA IS DESIGNED
TO WEED OUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THIS KIND OF
GANG MENTALITY. I WANT TO MAKE
CHANGES TO YOUR QUESTION IT'S
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS YOU MIGHT
BE BRINGING ON. AREN'T
SUSCEPTIBLE TO BECOMING GANG
MEMBERS THEMSELVES WORK WORK
WELL SOMETIMES IT'S THEM
BECOMING SOMETIMES ARE ALSO
PART OF SOME CLICK BEFORE HAND-
AND IT'S JUST SORT OF- MAYBE
INSTITUTIONALIZED OR FOMENTED-
EVEN MORE DEEPLY WITH THEM
COMING INTO A PARTICULAR
DIVISION OR DEPARTMENT- BUT
REGARDLESS I THINK WE HAVE TO
FIND A BETTER WAY. OF ANALYZING
THE CULTURE IN THESE PARTICULAR
DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S NOT A BREEDING GROUND FOR
THIS AND OR THAT WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY SOME OF THAT YOU KNOW
MARKERS IN THE PARTICULAR
DIVISION OR DEPARTMENT- THAT
ARE. LEADING SOME OF THIS
ACTIVITY AND BEHAVIOR BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY- THOSE THINGS EIGHT
ELEVATE DISTRUST. DE ESCALATE
FEAR. C. RESULT AND LAWSUITS
MISCONDUCT- INTEGRATOR AROSE IN
OF THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITY. YEAH
OKAY STAND NOW- I THINK FIRST
OF ALL WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
SCREENING SCREENING WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON A MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION THAT'S DONE FOR ALL
POSSIBLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND THEN I THINK TO
BUTTRESS ON YOUR LAST QUESTION.
I THINK WE NEED. ONCE I'M
HIRING I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CHECK UPS
THROUGHOUT PEOPLE'S CAREER I
THINK WE SHOULD BE DOING PRE
HAB BECAUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
A TRAUMA BASED PROFESSION SO WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN DRAMA I'M GOING TO
RESPOND IN A CERTAIN WAY AND
ONE OF THOSE WAYS COULD BE TO
BECOME VIOLENT THEMSELVES AND
TO TAKE A LOT OF BULLYING. OF
PERSONALITY THEMSELVES COULD BE
THERE BEFORE THEY GET IN OR
THEY COULD DEVELOP IT SO BY
DOING THE MENTAL HEALTH
CHECKUPS BY DOING THE PRE HAPPY
PEOPLE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO-
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS ALONG THE
WAY- I ALSO HAVE TO SAY THAT- I
WANT TO ANSWER THE QUESTION YOU
ASKED SHERIFF. OKAY AS- MENTAL
HEALTH AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FIRST RESPONDERS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME- TWO YEARS AGO
I PUT ON A CONFERENCE IN SANTA
BARBARA ABOUT JUST THAT. I'M
BECAUSE- MY SON IS A
FIREFIGHTER HOUSTON HE WAS HAD
POST TRAUMATIC INJURIES RESULT
SAVING. OKAY YOU KNOW TWO
HUNDRED FAMILIES ALONG WITH ALL
THE OTHER FIREFIGHTERS SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND THE KINDS OF
THINGS HE SAW THAT NIGHT WILL
STICK WITH HIM FOREVER. AS A
RESULT OF THAT HE JOINED THE
PEER SUPPORT ANY ALSO GOT A
COMFORT DOG THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
SO THAT WHEN THE FIREFIGHTERS
BEEN TO OUR- RIFIC EVENT. HE
GOES THERE WITH HIS PEER
SUPPORT JACKET HIS JOB TO HELP
THEM COME ALONG. NO I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO THE FIRST
RESPONDER BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITY IF
WE HAVE TRAUMATIZED FIRST
RESPONDERS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE WELL EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH
THAT KIND OF TRAUMA. THEY GONNA
HAVE TO FACE THE VERY NEXT DAY.
WELL TRUE THAT'S TRUE. I'M I.
JERRY BROWN YEAH THIS CAME UP
IN OUR- DISCUSSION AND IT WAS A
QUESTIONS FLASHPOINT OF
CONVERSATION- WHICH I HOPE OUR-
WAY WILL KIND OF INFORM THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO DO ON
POST IT SOUNDS LIKE IT WILL.
BUT YOU DID ADAM MENTIONED THAT
YOUR FIFTH DAY ON THE JOB YOUR
UNIT RESPONDED TO THE RODNEY
KING INCIDENT- WHICH IN MY MIND
SEEM TO BE THE GENESIS OF SORT
OF YOU KNOW PUBLIC RECORDINGS
AND SHARING- HOW OFFICERS
INTERACT WITH SUBDUE WOULD DE
ESCALATE- THE FOLKS THAT THEY
COME INTO CONTACT WITH AND THEN
FAST FORWARD. YOU KNOW WE JUST
BEEN TWO YEAR DEALING WITH-
DEREK CHAU VAN AND GEORGE
FLOYD. AND THERE'S SO MUCH
IRONY- IN THAT BECAUSE SOME
FOLKS WOULD ARGUE THAT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY. MADE HUGE
CHANGES- AND HOW OFFICERS.
RESPOND TO CERTAIN FOLKS INTO
CERTAIN SITUATIONS I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW YOUR SORT OF
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
IN URBAN BEEN AND RURAL. YOU'VE
OBVIOUSLY ELEVATED- IN RANK
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS- AND- I
MEAN. IS THERE HOPE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE- IN THE FACT THAT
CHANGE HAS BEEN MADE BECAUSE
FOR SOME IT WOULD SEEM NOT AT
ALL FOR OTHERS IT WOULD SEEM
IMPERCEPTIBLE. BUT THAT
CERTAINLY CANNOT BE THE
NARRATIVE. RIGHT SO CHANGE HAS
BEEN MADE BUT I WOULDN'T SAY
THAT NATIONWIDE CHANGES THAT.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
LEADER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
HOW WE APPROACH THINGS AND
CERTAINLY THE RODNEY KING
INCIDENT WAS A SEMINAL MOMENT
AND IT CHANGED LAW ENFORCEMENT
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY
LOS EXPERTS FROM THE WEST
COAST. WE DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY
AND IT TAKES THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY WILL THEY CATCH UP AND
WHAT HAPPENS SHE DIRECTLY. WITH
ORDER AND THEIR SHARED.
HORRIBLE. I'M SURE GIVE ALL IT
SAID IT AND I DON'T KNOW
ANYBODY IN LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO.
OKAY YOU SAID WHAT HAPPENED
THERE WAS RIGHT I DON'T KNOW
ANYBODY WHO SUPPORTS THAT. BUT
IT HAPPENED SO WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AGAIN SO WE DO NEED A
NATIONWIDE CHAIN I THINK
THERE'S MORE NATIONAL EFFORTS-
STANDARDIZATION ON THIS THE
CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS BEEN A
LEADER IN THERE IS EVEN A
RODNEY KING THAT THEY WERE
HEALTHY AFTER AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WHERE THEY WERE CONVICTED
OF EXCESSIVE FORCE YOU OUT OF
THE FOR WORK- IN THERE IS HOPE
IN THE FACT THAT THERE SHOULD
WAS CONVICTED OF MURDER WHICH
NEVER USED TO HAPPEN. IN A LOT
OF FIRST USE. OF FORCE CASE. SO
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN TO THE
FIRST PLACE BUT IT DOES HAPPEN
YOU SHOULD BE THE CAMP FOR. AND
THAT. THERE THERE IS. BUT
SCHIFF- SO YES TO ANSWER. THE
QUESTION THAT WAS MY FIFTH DAY
ON THE JOB I WAS RUNNING IN AND
IT DID CHANGE. MY CAREER SO I
DON'T KNOW A MICROTURBINE
ABOUT. WHAT I STILL BE HERE
WOULD BE HERE RIGHT NOW I DON'T
KNOW. SOMETIMES I LOOK AT
MYSELF IN THE MIRROR AND SAY
HOW DID YOU GET HERE- I NEVER
EXPECTED. TO BE IN EXACTLY
WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE. IF
THAT MAKES SENSE. IT DOES. IT
AT EACH TAUGHT ME A LOT IT
TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT EMPATHY
IT TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT AS I
WORK INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR SIX
YEARS BUT I STARTED MY CAREER
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE
S. NUMBER BEING INTERVIEWED BY.
SO I'VE LEARNED. A LOT OF IS A
LEADER HOW TO TREAT PEOPLE HOW
TO TREAT A COMMUNITY HAS SHARE
INFORMATION WITH THE COMMUNITY
TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE NOT HOLDING
ANYTHING BACK BECAUSE ANYTHING
THAT YOU ALL BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY THE
SITUATION LIKE THAT IT WILL
COME TO LIGHT ACTUALLY IF
YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK LIKE A FOR
PROFIT SHARING WE NEED TO BE
TRANSPARENT WE NEED SURE
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN SHARE
AND AS SOON AS WE CAN HERE AND
THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF. THE BODY
WORN CAMERAS IN THE HURDY
ANALYSIS WHAT WAS UNEXPECTED
WITH THE RODNEY KING INCIDENT
BECAUSE NOBODY WAS EXPECTING
THAT THAT WAS DONE I'VE NEVER
HEARD ANYBODY ELSE DOWN YEAH IS
THAT STANDARD WE KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING WE DO ALL DAY EVERY
DAY IT'S RECORDING AND IF YOU
HAVE PASSED YOUR JOB TO THE
BEST OF YOUR ABILITY. AND TO BE
MINDFUL THAT EVERYTHING YOU DO
AND SAY WELL IF RECORDED
SOMEBODY WILL SEE IT AND YOU
SHOULD DO YOUR JOB RIGHT YOU
SHOULD DO YOUR JOB RIGHT ANYWAY.
WHAT BUT YOU ARE BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE- INTERNET. PEOPLE
ARE ONCE AND THAT'S CHANGED
EVERYTHING WITH RUNNING PEOPLE
ARE WHAT AND THEY SHOULD BE
WATCH WE SHOULD BE WATCHING A
LOT WHAT WE GIVE IS VERY PUBLIC
YOUR SAFETY AND THEY SHOULD BE
WHAT WE GET WE SHOULD BE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I CAN. AGREE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE WATCHING US
ALL THE TIME TO- I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL BOTH FOR YOUR-
WILLINGNESS AND DESIRE TO DO
THAT JOB SHERIFF AND TO
CONTINUE TO DO THE JOB. SHARE
DEADLY AND- JUST WANNA LEAVE
YOU WITH THE FACT THAT I THINK
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
WORDS- FOR POST AND FOR THIS
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
TRUST. AND HOW WE FIND WAYS TO
BUILD IT. AND SUSTAIN IT- IT IS
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
BUILDING BLOCK. OUT WE CAN.
ELEVATE IN THIS KIND OF WORK SO
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT- IN BOTH OF YOUR
PROFESSIONS- TO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE WITH POST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR- WELL THAT'S
BEEN A ACTUALLY A REALLY GOOD
DISCUSSION- EVEN AND ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE HAVING TO COME
AND GO I THINK WE'VE HAD A
PRETTY ROBUST. CONVERSATION I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THE QUESTIONS- SO I AM PREPARED
TO GO AHEAD AND MOVED TO.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
MAY BE HERE TO TESTIFY FIRST IN
SUPPORT. SO RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I WILL
SEE IF WE HAVE PEOPLE ALREADY
TO TESTIFY BUT I AGAIN SHOULD
OBVIOUSLY. REMIND FOR WITNESSES
WHO WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. VIA PHONE THAT
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER. IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT TWO ONE
FIVE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT TWO ONE FIVE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT TWO NINE ONE. ONE ZERO
ZERO EIGHT TWO NINE ONE. SO LET
ME JUST SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
THAT WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
APPROACHING THE DYESS SO I AM
GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL BEGIN AND AS A
REMINDER TO THE WITNESSES.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THAT WHEN YOU
SPEAK YOU PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY POSITION ON
THE APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER
PLEASE SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY. WELCOME BACK MR
MODERATOR. THANK YOU YOU LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT'S A ONE AND THEN AS
THEIR- ON YOUR TELEPHONE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE. WE WILL GO
FIRST TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I LINE TWENTY
SEVEN ARE YOU POSSIBLY ON MUTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS KAREN
SENATORS LUCHON MUCH FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
APPOINTMENT OF SHARE IN GREG
BRAUN AND REAPPOINTMENT- THE
JOYS THAT LEAD. TO THE
COMMISSION IRONED OUT PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS MY NAME IS
ROBERT LAWTON I AM THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER OF MONO
COUNTY- AND IT'S BEEN MY
PLEASURE TO SERVE WITH SHARE
BROAD AND SHE HAS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. ONE TWENTY FIVE. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR TAKING MY COMMENT THIS
IS STACEY SIMON I AM THE COUNTY
COUNCIL FOR MONO COUNTY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
APPOINTMENT OF INGRID BRAUN IS
A MEMBER OF THE POST COMMISSION
BUT SOMEONE WHO'S WORKED WITH
SHERIFF RON FOR THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS I CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT
YOU WILL NOT FIND SOMEONE
SMARTER MORE ARTICULATE OR
MORE. REASONABLE N. INGRID
BRON. AND I SUPPORT HER
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU- BLIND NOW THAT
THAT'S OUT POLITIES MY I HAD A
COMPUTER ISSUE THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME NO WORRIES THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN IN JUST A MOMENT SO HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF WE WILL
NOW COME BACK INTO ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE TO SEE IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
SEE THAT WE STILL HAVE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
HERE. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SO
ARE MISTER MODERATOR I'M COMING
BACK TO YOU- TO PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
LIKE TO STATE YOUR OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. MISTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR HELP AND YOUR ASSISTANCE
TODAY WE GREATLY APPRECIATE IT-
SO THANK YOU. WE WILL ARE NOW
HAVING. HEARD FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY WHO CALLED IN
SUPPORT. I THERE WERE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS AND- OF WE HAD
CENTER EARLIER QUITE A
WONDERFUL. CONVERSATION DESPITE
THE COMINGS AND GOINGS OF
SENATORS WITH MULTIPLE ROLES
TODAY ODD DID YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
WANTED TO ASK OR COMMENT ON
ANYTHING. OKAY I'M GOOD THANK
YOU. I AM HAPPY TO TAKE A
MOTION AND- OKAY IN IT I WILL
LET MADAM VICE CHAIR MAKE THE
MOTION AND I BELIEVE WE ARE
TAKING UP BOTH APPOINT
APPOINTMENTS I DON'T SEE ANYONE
DESIRING TO SEPARATE OUT THE
MOTION. SO WITH THAT OUR MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE BY THE VICE CHAIR
OF MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ROVE HI ROBERT
HI KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES AYE.
AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS FIVE.
ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO- THE
APPOINTMENTS WILL BE MOVED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONFIRMATION. LET ME THANK BOTH
OF YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL.
DIALOGUE TODAY I POST HAS
BECOME AN INCREASINGLY AND
INCREDIBLY. I HIGHLIGHTED.
COMMISSIONED AND CERTAINLY IN
THE MINDS OF OUR SENATE. AS
WELL AS PROBABLY THE
LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE SO I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE SERVICE- AND
CERTAINLY THE WEIGHT OF WHAT
YOU ARE HAVING TO LOOK AT TODAY
I FEEL VERY GOOD- WITH ALL OF
THE MEMBERS OF POST THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL IN RECENT.
MONTHS AND SO CONGRATULATIONS
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY UCH WELL THANK YOU OKAY-
WE ARE- AT THE END OF THE
AGENDA IT CAN GOOD CONCLUDES
OUR AGENDA SO LET ME JUST THANK
EVERYBODY ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS- YOUR
COMMENTS CERTAINLY AND YOUR
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. SO EVERYONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
YOUR COOPERATION OUR SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES IS NOW
ADJOURNED.